right
[Music]
[Applause]
yes yes yes
[Music]
we're back
we're so back baby
that's right my son is back from uh
celebrating the royal coronation that's
right that's right I've I'm back
which let's be real Hassan what the what
the f dude you're out there having tea
and krumpus to celebrate King sausage
fingers I mean who are you it's time
it's time to admit something Ethan I've
I've always been British my whole life
yes that's right I've I've been
betraying myself
as an American man but also a Turkish
one but in reality much like Boris
Johnson who is also Turkish
that is real by the way look it up
he's an ottoman son
ja I touch it
have been infiltrating American spaces
at the behest of the queen
well I'll have you know I always knew
that you weren't American there was just
something off about you bro yes yeah
thank you I'm not surprised by that
but welcome back it's good to be back
ladies and gentlemen finally in the land
of Freedom domestic terrorists
I saw like when I travel I'm not a big
travel fan I'm not a big travel fan I
don't like leaving my house that much
which I think I feel that you yeah you
definitely agree with that
and I uh you know there was only one
time
where I felt sad coming back to the
United States of America that was when I
came back from Japan yeah when I come
back from London I was literally about
to kiss the [__] border patrol guy
right like I I felt like I had finally
breached containment like I had left and
and was back on like you know Freedom
soil is the food horrible there were
they serving you beans on toast for
breakfast yes yeah bro dude okay okay
sorry the food is so [__] garbage
dude it is so bad like it it's just
entirely carried by its colonies
obviously like there's there's really
good Indian food uh I've heard that
there's really good Caribbean food uh I
wasn't able to to try that out and
London is really interesting because
it's like it's a Cosmopolitan City
obviously it has like some of the best
like Michelin star rated restaurants on
the planet
but like if you go to like an average
place if you go to like a regular place
to grab a quick eat a quick bite yeah
it's so garbage what's a quick bite in
England
jelly deals
jellied eels Yeti jellied jelly deals no
they have like the [__] I'll tell you
this I'll tell you this like British
food like actually British Cuisine feels
like uh like a liminal state is that
like a liminal space Sorry like uh it's
supposed to be something like your eyes
look at it and you're like this
resembles food
but like it's it's a little off you know
what what is it that they actually eat
on the street like what do they grab on
the go what are those it's mostly just
like you know kebabs kebabs like that
yeah but oh dude nobody eats that no
they do no people eat it dude if you eat
that you should die I mean yeah people
are dying I think I think the Tsum
strowman people and the jelly eel people
need to get together
so awful I've had it too many times
[__] ruined money yesterday we ate it
yesterday oh you did yeah yesterday's
episode was such a disaster we had this
guy hunger FF on who's like the world
famous prolapser he made a dildo
related guy
he tied into that that was Howie he's
not the guy oh he's not he's
stealing prolapse Valor no no he no no
he's got Valor that's not the problem
okay the problem was
is he was calling in the show to talk
about his new prolapse dildo that he
made first of its kind I saw it you saw
that you showed they showed it to me
when I came in so we had other people
what you said about us I have a very
controversial opinion on it it doesn't
look scary at all it looks tasty what do
I mean by that you might ask well you
just came back from England so I don't
no it looks like it looks like cockroach
which is uh one of my favorite uh
Turkish foods the Sheep intestines
that's human intestines
uh right oh that's why it looks like
that oh okay that makes sense it
literally put some rice and and good
stuff in there oh it's good to work oh
you're supposed to like cut it like very
finely like you're supposed to chop it
with like tomatoes onions Peppers
spices well not the human one the Sheep
one and it's delicious yeah this is it
right yeah exactly
yeah and then the final product is in
the bread it look if you scroll down
there's like one
yeah that's how you're supposed to eat
it it's a late night eat it's one of my
favorite things to eat it's so it's so
[__] delicious and hunger's fully
prolapse anus is what made you think of
that yeah because it looks identical
does it not yeah just raw and the raw
form
but uh anyway not only do you show his
master prolapsed dildos in the
background but he also there was a
picture right behind him of a naked dude
people were wondering if it was it
wasn't just the dildos it was the naked
dude in back with his [__] out
yeah that's yeah yeah that was the one
that made me think like do you think
Clan engages in homophobia again what
else is new
star on this he's been slacking dark
Hawk listen yeah I'm Pro [__]
[Applause]
anyway he really it was really for years
I'm sorry I love hunger but that was
that was [__] up what he did to us
like we we coached him so thoroughly on
what to do and what not trying to get it
trying to tell gay man to to do certain
things okay so close to pride month
um yeah
you know do they have frozen pizza in
England I wonder I'm sure they do it's
probably [__] nasty worse than it is
it's even worse than like American
frozen pizza probably I mean it's just
like what I was gonna say is this the
reason why I say this like a is the
correct term liminal State isn't that
what it is like when you uh liminal
space like when you look at something
that's like weird and your brain can't
like wrap itself
so I'm on I'm on British Airways coming
back home okay and they have like
sandwiches that they're offering if
you're hungry and I'm a hungry boy they
were not giving me enough food so
I go in and I go and raid the sandwich
cabinet
and they have a sandwich in there called
the plowman's sandwich right and you
look at it and you're like what what
would like a basic ass sandwich like put
some [__] ham and cheese in like
maybe a shredded lettuce and like I'm
good right yeah the plowman sandwich is
like
is like pickles and cheese
but like not even Cornish pickles like
like jellied pickles you know American
food's not that bad people come they
laugh at us you know what I mean like we
know how to throw a sandwich together
plowmans yeah and also like these babies
they cut the crust off it's like are you
are you just a country
like I like crust but I don't mind it if
they could but it's it's like dude you
know what I mean like grow up England
and then another one coronation chicken
coronation chicken sandwich and that one
was like a curry chicken sandwich it was
like odd again with the crust cut off
English people grow the [__] up dude a
lot of this looks way better edible I'm
sorry I have to say this they colonize
half the world who's in hunger and
they're cutting off the crust how dare
you well they also rarely use the
[__] spices to the king
wow controversial
um another thing was I went to by the
way the reason I say that so people
don't get mad at me all right let me
just let me just
uh Tom did you see this Tom Segura he
went to Ireland I think or Scotland
it was so funny oh no see he said [__]
the king not death to the king yeah
[__]
I almost hit the button on that
[Music]
crazy yeah of course
what do you mean it's just funny like
they give him a standing oh for like a
full minute
yeah
Irish people love
Irish people love saying [__] like that
oh
unless you're talking to some
Protestants
all right so
um yeah but long live the king whatever
I don't know
not death to anybody no death to anybody
I meant to say [__] the king but
you know how it is around here
um you didn't mean like a specific King
I I think it's like valid to say you
know death I was talking about Charles
you don't have to clear I was talking
about you don't have to clarify how are
you gonna milk it out it was him it was
him okay
you're about to make a coronation
coronation sandwich am I saying the MI6
is coming after Harry and Megan
yesterday in New York they can come
after you too [__] you better
watch yourself [__] I've told you I'm a
part of the British intelligence service
so anyway we have a ton of stories
actually
uh the three main stories
that I've got here is Elon entering his
uh Nazi era oh yeah he's spots on that
he's getting
and I love saying this about a 50 year
old man red pilled
I love that it's like right you're not a
[__] teenager in an online Forum dog
you're like a 50 year old man absolutely
with like a hundred children
right okay I mean I I'm for right what's
wrong with you and then the other one is
Return of the queen AKA not well Diana
uh Diana Feinstein who's not in a box
like Queen Elizabeth but who
um
could be soon
could be in a box soon would be a great
relief to many Dianne Feinstein is in a
prison of her own mind right now she is
unfortunately uh in the throes of late
stage dementia
and for years your brain is jello I mean
yeah that goes on for a long time like
my grandmother had Alzheimer's she
passed away a couple years ago and it
went on for like 10 years you know what
I mean like especially with a lot of
medical care you can keep someone alive
well it was that clip of her being
asking the same question twice was three
years ago like she's had a lot of time
to deteriorate yeah it goes on for
longer than that you can go on for like
a decade maybe even two decades really
uh it's just entirely dependent on how
well uh taken care of she is and it
seems like she's got a great medical
team oh yeah just there they are Weekend
at Bernie's 100 and she's just a cadaver
being held up by marionettes yeah but
hey you know that's like a lot of our
politicians and then the other one is
Rudy Giuliani who's being faced with a
10 million dollar lawsuit for basically
essaying this uh former aide who's got a
lot of tea I mean he is a he is so gross
like I don't want to sound
this is gonna sound bad
and so keep your hand on the button dude
my mouse is hovering over the button
being being essayed horrible
oh you're saying it's extra bad because
it's Rudy Giuliani because he's so vile
yeah I mean usually a lot of I think a
lot of sexual assaulters are vile and
gross regardless but right but he's got
it in the world when it's Rudy Giuliani
he's got to be the most vile person in
the world disgusting he is disgusting
his dick has tonsil stones oh dude come
on oh God I can't believe we're so we're
back we're back we're back to England I
just came to England to avoid this okay
but that's that's my point he's so vile
he's s yeah he's s tier creep yeah so
those are the three uh main ones I want
to talk about but there's some good
stuff at the top as well so yeah
um
oh the other thing I was going to say is
as far as England goes
uh we went to the Ritz for high tea to
celebrate the king's coronation I have a
picture of that up you can pull it up if
you want um and
I gotta say very mid like yeah of course
he's stupid as [__] it was mid like they
have sandwiches and scones and like
pastries rust stuff no crust look you
can see one of the sandwiches there but
like the sandwiches are not that good at
all
I'm yeah I I got Austin for the bill I
think it was like 500 quid uh I don't
get quit for that yeah because it was a
big tape we had like a bunch of people
okay okay we were like five people and
are you supposed to dress up this nice
yes no they literally won't let you in
unless you have a suit and tie for
Uncrustables for yeah for uh formal
apparel all the way down as a matter of
fact
I had to go buy we all had to go buy
suits last second uh we bought our suits
I had a I had boots on luckily that I
had brought to England because I thought
it was going to rain a lot uh so I wore
those which was fine but I didn't have a
tie so as soon as I walk in there's like
a person playing the harp and it's like
this you know everyone is like 85 years
old
um this lady runs up to me says no no
you mustn't come in and I was like what
the [__] wait why what the hell she's
like you do not have a tie oh my God
please see yourself to the uh I don't
know the English there's a room where
they have like they give you loners they
have loner ties yeah they have loaner
ties they have loaner jackets they have
everything English just can't be helped
I don't know what to say you know why
they don't put crust on the sandwiches
because they save it for the royalty or
they're crusty old asses you are so
focused on the crow you love the [__]
crust it's just it to me it's so [__]
silly I mean I don't really I cut the
crust off for my four-year-old son I I I
I don't really care about it one way or
the other like I I like the crust of the
sandwich I don't have an issue with it
but I I I certainly do not have as big
as a distaste for the people put the
crust off all right so it's way worse
stuff about British food than just the
crust being taken remove being taken off
here is some memes let's see the LGBT
community has forgiven Hassan thank you
what did they what did you do to them
all right is it is an ongoing meme that
I like I hate the term Ally I think it's
like so I don't know it's like very
liberal I'm an ally yeah I I hate it so
I always say I'm an lgbtful okay and
because my community is like very gay
like I have a massively queer uh
audience so it's just like an inside
meme
that's pretty funny oh yeah and of
course Austin is gay right yeah he's
this is him yeah and I I [__] on him all
the time so like in a homophobic way
okay good yeah okay you're gay uh
Crowder here's just a few stuff at the
top here Crowder I can't get enough of
his uh
he's fundraising that's what he's saying
to YouTube
they uh let's see here can you link me
the tweet I prefer that over the the
email but he tweeted the same thing he
recently got five videos removed and
only one strike this man still has a
YouTube channel Alex Jones hosted his
show and did uh
like yeah here I mean I have a
screenshot because I have a conversation
Pig on this day you might not agree
here's Alex Jones on
no yep that's what he that's where they
got the strike for and I would love to
watch the video but I'm just gonna show
the picture that's insane dog that video
the video is so much worse oh can you
just can we just hear the audio Yeah you
can probably play it if we don't show it
it's probably okay let's just say
because I haven't seen it it got removed
from Crowder's channel oh uh that that
episode so uh well then they removed all
of Alex's guests this is like one of
those things where it's like it's so
over the top races that it like rolls
back around and becomes funny again for
me at least I know people will get mad
at me for saying that but like that's so
insane like what the [__] are you doing
the context if you can believe it
actually makes it more insane they were
having a conversation about uh like
anti-asian discrimination and like hate
crimes like and he sided with the hate
crimes like what yes well that's their
stance pretty much that's no no they
weren't siding with that they were
talking about how terrible this was or
whatever and then Alex Jones just out of
nowhere is like oh by the way I'm Asian
and then starts doing like a Chinese
voice so here's Steven was like this is
fire this is great content this is the
funniest thing I've ever seen probably
that's what he thought so uh Crowder
Steven victim complex Crowder is uh
declaring his 10th War this year on
YouTube
[__] you at YouTube I don't give a [__]
that we're one strike away from being
banned permanently dude he's from the
platform God he's so cool that doesn't
work for me either he's so sick
this doesn't square with the baby [__]
boy voice that we've heard we will not
pacify we will not kowtow and we will
we won't
stop
we will say when it's over
says when it's over
hit that last one
you want me to say that got some patsies
don't miss tomorrow's episode
the stakes have never been higher it's
like nobody transparent that this is the
Griff it's so [__] transparent like
you are such a dumbass if you look at
this and go wow he's doing such like a
brave and he's taking a Brave and Bold
stance like over and over again against
[__] YouTube and The Stance is what
getting Alex Jones to host of your show
and do like
like you know
this 2007 YouTube memes
more like 1950 grandpa I mean well I
mean I'm just saying there was like this
is this this style of content was like
very very well yeah when I was 13 that
was cool I mean I I
yeah I guess anyway I feel like that
[__] banged on YouTube though for like
for like a long time like 2014 is like
the last time you could do that and get
away with it and then everyone had to
delete those old videos and old tweets
of them making fun of Asian people in an
identical fashion yeah but uh he's
actually fundraising on this too it's
it's identical to his tweet
and he's he really wants people on that
mug club man I'll tell you what boy I'll
tell you what man that Mud Club
something else yeah he's I mean I'll
drop the video what's going on we know
it's in the it's in the dog we know
exactly what this is I mean he outlined
that this was his like which one
business strategy
when that uh Jeremy boring back and
forth happened if you remember where he
very openly was saying like no I want to
get banned so I can like Drive traffic
to The Mug club for my only Clans you
know what I mean like for where I can be
like extra racist uh and and that's like
our business strategy that's how we
drive that's what we generate Revenue
um and that's precisely what he's doing
and his fan base is like they're so
stupid I don't know how to describe I
mean I guess you know yeah they're
looking for their kind of content so
yeah of course they're stupid they're
dumb and also maybe
are old people watching Crowder
because I feel like old people fall for
any damn thing middle-aged divorcees
okay yeah I think there's a lot of yeah
there's a lot of like 35 Plus probably
that watch them yeah I know for a fact
that I'm the youngest I have the
youngest audience on on uh politics
across the board on YouTube like
literally the youngest
we are we are here and we are young yeah
here is the um Here's the the voice I
haven't heard it yeah I wasn't gonna say
the other point I probably don't show
this Ian yeah don't show it let's just
let's just listen to it please be
prepared that's part of yeah oh great
great good calling that's exactly what
we need yeah oh thank God we got a
dumbass well just last week uh the the
uh the Attorney General came out with a
new rule saying no crime statistics can
be used by the FBI well how do you put
yeah definitely in areas if you don't
know where the crime it's like if you're
fishing you've got you know sonar to see
where the fish are so they're saying oh
well we're not even going to look at
where crime's at well the the natural
thing for me to do would be like okay so
you're telling me that it's unsafe for
me right now as a person this guy's such
a [__] piece
by the way you do is this a new thing is
there a benefit
[Laughter]
why are they even laughing at that it's
like
you really they sound uncomfortable and
you hear somebody say they're like stop
it you're a child like I think like they
can't like go too hard but I think even
those guys are like holy [__] Alex was
this mid it's it's mid it's like
but humor wise if I am to analyze this
as like just simply comedy or an
attempted comedy right it's just it's
even worse than Stephen Crowder's bits
which I did not think was possible right
this is what you do when you're like a
14 year old and go ahead and show this
stuff and you want to be you want to be
[__] edgy you know what I mean you're
like like you wanna you can't be funny
you're not creative enough right to make
people laugh so you're just like trying
to get a reaction by being like amazing
I did it yeah look at me I'm Asian haha
like literally so this was live they did
not choose to upload this is that right
yeah yeah no they they always stream
their show okay so I'm not I'm not bro
I'm I'm saying it right now I'm a button
I don't have a button but it's just it
this is like again
it's so desperate to be edgy that I
think it removes The Edge from it and it
all of a sudden Loops back around to
being like funny
show it you know what I mean it's like
because
watch it
all right it's one of those things that
says like significantly like looking at
this is nowhere near as frustrating as
like you know what Stephen Crowder did
with like the George Floyd execution uh
Recreation you know what I mean because
like there's a deliberate attempt to
to to basically vilify black people
there
um whereas in this one
you tried
you swung and you missed so hard I don't
know I see I hear uproarious laughter
boy
and you missed so hard that it it
basically uh made you look way worse
rather than like invoke any kind of like
negative reaction I think I don't think
you can look worse than Alex Jones
[Music]
I think everybody's fair game do people
still use the Paco says I save Alex
quick let me do an impression of a white
person
see I'm not ready it's just myself I'm
just gonna be myself for a second does
that make sense do you understand what
I'm trying to say like yeah
back around and like it softened the the
uh
like it softened the edge of it almost I
get it bro like he is oozing with a
divorce dad uh pathetic Aura which
Stephen also is uh you know they're
Kinder he's joining Club divorce dad
he
let me look it up I I seem to recall
that he got divorced recently but I
could be mistaken I'll explain this too
let me finish this my name's Yosemite
Sam people pray for me right yes he is
divorced he spied on his ex-wife uh was
a story last year
um it's awesome how did he spy on her
uh he was like hacking her phone or
something wait what he had like software
oh yeah yeah well yeah Alex Jones is a
[__] Alex Jones is literally like the
the Elden ring boss of divorced dad
um he once famously flew a helicopter
around his uh his his uh estranged like
divorced wives house with the children
inside terrifying them in a helicopter
yeah he's like he is a complete [__]
freak from his ex Alex is obsessed with
me has had me followed for years has
done everything to infringe on my
Liberties and personal freedoms to
impose himself into my life Kelly Jones
said my life is a gauntlet of waiting
for his next nefarious and disingenuous
or overtly threatening move oh I believe
that sounds about right he's like a
one-man Scientology
pecker
give me some whiskey oh boy oh gosh this
is all right so whatever I guess that's
why you needed these so shout out Alex
Jones you guys are really uh doing
important work over there on louder with
Crowder and uh we're we're real proud of
you guys over there it's not funny also
Blair white who I generally have a
strong distaste for how they act she's
like so
is it so Ollie London I mean straight up
you know uh just just willing to throw
every trans person under the bus just
for a little crumb of clout from the
right but here she is actually uh with
an interesting admission have you seen
this Hassan I mean this is what she does
for the record that's true she always
yeah no she's done this like a bunch of
different times if you like and I I
don't really know anything about her I
don't really follow her consumer content
at all even like uh to [__] on it
because I think she's like a non-entity
she's Irrelevant in the grand scheme of
things uh you nailed it though she is
like uh a classic uh trans person who
hates uh other trans people basically
and she's the Candace Owens of like the
trans uh conservative movement which is
like three people it is um literally
three bills Blair Ollie and um Caitlin
Caitlyn yeah that's the whole so that's
the that's the Triforce so which by the
way there's a really funny thing about
Caitlyn Jenner and Matt Walsh talking to
one another where Matt Walsh is actually
correct which uh we can look at in a
second but what I was going to say is so
uh Blair does this stuff all the time
like if you recall she did um she had
like a like a video where she was like
all conservative commentators lie all
the time they always like
um these these smaller conservative
content creators regularly will try to
like try to do drama and do a lot of the
way there's been fighting in the same
way that like leftists love doing uh all
the time and this is this is nothing new
uh with her well you said this before
she's done stuff like yeah maybe it's
not that interesting but I'll play it
anyway it's short how they act I'm
talking about political commentators not
just people on the right none of these
hoes uh live how they act the amount of
demented people
okay I'll go off you want me to go off
I'll go off yes the amount of demented
people that are in
spill the teeth the right-wing
commentary sphere is actually scary
that's your friends by the way you're
talking about your friends you're
talking about the people that literally
think you're a freak that probably would
be happy if you didn't exist yeah nice I
hope you enjoy the clout
um one thing that the libs do you have
correct
they're right about [__] ever so rarely
but they're right about this
yeah that's awesome eat a lot of these
not all of them but a lot of these Pro
Family Values people on the right that
become famous for that live like
absolute monsters to generates in real
life that's your people orgies codes
yeah that's your people so like but if
they're lie about that that's the
foundation of their whole identity then
their their whole personality everything
they do is a lot I'm gonna stop Blair
here for a second and defend Stephen
Crowder
[Laughter]
Stephen Crowder was living out his
[__] values on camera that wasn't
like anything outside of the norm like
mistreating your insanely pregnant wife
who was barefoot and pregnant inside of
your house is like a
you know it's a pillar of conservatives
that's a fair point he's being true
being a hyper-controlling uh and an
absolute Freakazoid uh that is very much
a conservative principle he has said it
on camera the only difference is you got
to see what it looks like in action and
when you see what it looks like in
action it's a little bit different than
saying like women should stay in the
kitchen and like women actually enjoy uh
being a happy wife happy life uh uh
style uh Trad wife for me Stephen
Crowder like when you say that on camera
it's very different than like actually
living that experience on camera in a
ring footage I feel that was Unearthed
by the the uh ex-wife that's another
family yeah that's a good secretly gay
that's another thing to write about
these lips are doing a lot of these um
right-wing commentators who talk about
gay stuff you speak in my language
absolutely gay they're right she sounds
just like me when I saw this I've grown
because of like oh Ethan Ethan's gonna
love this you always say that and I
always try and push back but it's true
there are some who aren't though like I
don't think Matt Walsh is gay no I don't
think Matt I think Matt Walsh is a
hateful little Gremlin like he's just a
sweaty he's a classy I mean he doesn't
care he just wants he likes the
attention he gets by hating trans people
I think he generally [__] despises he
literally there was a leaked email with
him wasn't there where he was like I
just need to do whatever it takes to get
there right Stephen Crowder or no when
he got hacked I mean he's a psychopath
so you know what I mean he doesn't give
up yeah he's awful holy [__] bro what
this picture is cursed as [__]
Caitlyn made Ollie the uh spokesman for
they both look like bogdanovs at this
point I don't know what's going on yo
what happened I saw such a funny tweet
they said
why do all transphobes look like this
I mean it's a it's I shouldn't be giving
you some of these memes I feel like
because you're gonna use it
inappropriately but it's a very common
Trope in like uh trans circles is that
like turfs are bricked up always
um turfs are bricked up bricked up means
like you're not passing
it's it's actually an anti-trans thing
to say but trans people will always say
like perfect okay so go unpacked that
rigged up originally in trance circles
meant uh your brick like you're not
passing you're like very like uh you
just you're not passing as a as like
bricked up means boner right no huh it
does outside of trans so bricked up like
your physique is yeah
um so so anyway that's like so who's
bricked up turfs trans-exclusionary
radical feminine turfs aren't but turfs
aren't trans no they're not which is the
what what does it mean they're not
passing that's the entire point it's
that say they're not passing no let me
explain
gender as we all know is a social
construct it's an expression it's an
identity that you show to the rest of
the world for the most part it's uh in
in many respects removed from sex if you
want to consider sex as a as a separate
entity right
and it's not a rigid binary in the sense
that you know Ben Shapiro and the like
try to claim it is and uh the greatest
demonstration of the fact that gender is
an expression and not the rigid binary
is that a lot of these cisgender uh
heterosexual or or uh you know queer
sometimes uh turfs trans-exclusionary
radical feminists or you know anti-trans
people do not fit in the same rigid
confines that they espouse that they
claim uh gender is supposed to be as I
see you're CIS but you don't [__]
look like a woman
that's that's what that means okay
breakduck so I shouldn't say bricked up
like that in that concept no you could
say bricked up when you're talking about
you know uh I would say getting horny no
no no no no I want to use it now when
talking about trans issues it's just
bricked up all the time no don't use it
don't definitely don't use it well I
would never say that to a trans person
right that'd be awful you say it to like
uh you would say like uh the Hogwarts
lady is bricked up but she's she says
she's like normal
she's normal or I mean she's CIS is what
I mean by that so JK Rowling I would say
is probably the least bricked up Smurf
out there but like there are photos like
[__] here you want to pull this up so
type JK Rowling bricked up no no no no
no uh JK Rowling uh famously went to
like uh like a what was it like queers
against groomers or something or the
LGBT he did Foundation yeah she's like
super anti-trans I mean she's the queen
of the transphobia
um but she held like she went to an LGBT
Meetup or an LGB Meetup sorry and
[Music]
a BLT beat up
I looked up JK Rowling LGB Meetup and it
said did you mean JK Rowling LGBT Meetup
and the first article that comes out is
seven times JK Rowling supported LGBT
rights all right let's move on it's just
boring okay thank you Blair you're
derailing the show nobody cares blah all
right thank you uh next uh Nick Fuentes
talks about wanting to drink 16 year old
tit milk uh this guy continues to be
this is the dude who met with President
Trump who was touring with Thanksgiving
dinner with President Trump he's the man
perfect yeah he's the man dude he does
the show out of his mom's basement
literally yeah he's literally Will
Ferrell from that uh Wedding Crashers
mom meatloaf jazz
okay let's watch no [__] I want to
drink it straight from the tap I want it
raw I don't want to wait a moment right
when the milk is good I want to start
drinking the milk the same thing goes
with breasts I don't want to turn 30 and
find some 20 year old 29 year old woman
that I have something in common with and
it's like hey properly aged like wine
like permanently lonely like he's
[__] means you are it's such an
unfuckable little Gremlin like like he
has the option bro you know what I mean
you take what you can get you're almost
the creepiest little [__] Salad
Fingers dude it always freaks me out I
guess it's good for his booger eating
right you really do like deep excavation
yeah but like God damn his [__]
fingers are so [__] long it freaks me
out every time I see it all right let's
get into the good part fine women don't
age like wine they age like milk they
don't age like wine that's not how their
hormones work they work
yeah I gotta find I gotta find my 16
year old wife
probably when I turn 30 or something
because here's the thing I don't want to
be like
let's say I get married to us the 18
year old now
old six-year age difference loser gross
when I turned 40 she's going to be 34.
gross yeah that's [__] up well if I'm
30 and she's 16. 14 year age difference
when I'm 50 she'll be 36. that's what
I'm talking about when I was born
mental divorcer and get a new 16. yeah
that marriage is good for like 15 years
she'll be 26 and now we're talking here
now we're talking my heart sang a little
bit like the grossest
holy [__] this is like one of those
things where like you know I'm an
advocate for Free Speech but like maybe
not you know what I mean you know this
guy's he's not he's saying some Nazis
he's just saying pedophile [__] which is
you know open and then and then they
talk about how pedophiles are ruining
America and they're at the high levels
of government this man's just coming out
and saying damn bro you see EDP he
pulled the [__] uh transphobia
parachute cord too he did he's on the
we've got to save our children uh yeah
yeah no yeah which is [__] hilarious
and there and people are down with that
the cupcake no I think I think it's it's
uh it's actually probably worse for like
the conservative movement that like an
out and about open pedophile who is
most famous for being a pedophile
protect our kids oh I know how he wants
to protect the kids yeah no he means
like we must protect our kids from me
that's what he's saying yeah yeah you
see this face here don't let him
anywhere near him yeah but Nick Fuentes
this guy speaks at like
the highest level Republican rallies
there are CPAC at the turning point oh
he was banned from CPAP yeah he had to
do his own he had to do his own but like
wasn't hezar Marjorie Taylor or green
like you have prominent National
Republicans that have like appeared on
his uh
an alternative vision for how how things
could be
I want a 16 year old that's untouched
yes sir Christine
untouched that's my man innocent that's
what we all want what we all want
also kids love Hitler all kids love
Hitler yeah it's what we all want all 16
year olds want a older guy
who's like capable and strong
so not you and everything to uh sweep
off their feet that's what everybody
wants 16 is the age of consent everybody
wants yeah uh dude I don't know like
first of all this
I don't think anything needs to be said
about that yeah moving on thank you Nick
Fuentes it's what everybody wants and uh
thank you for finally saying what nobody
had the the ball say Lauren bobert
divorced her sex offender husband yeah
again Family Values at work who also was
uh exposed to her sex offender husband's
penis at the uh ripe age of 16 in the
same way that Nick Fuentes was just
talking about it so that's a fun little
segue
ew dude this is weird this is his this
is Nick Fuentes profile man on oh stop
dude oh my God
it's not right it's just not right
there's something so [__] freaky
uh the family values conservative woman
cites
irreconcilable differences for the
breakup while her husband of 20 years
allegedly lashed out and at a process
server now here's my favorite part
this is her husband who flashed his dick
to underage girls at a bowling alley
including Lobo
is that how he got her I think so
I'm not even kidding no really this is
uh I had never read this but here
there's actually the written
uh statement from from the girls
oh I did not see that yeah so this is
her husband of 20 years Trish and I were
sending standing at the snack bar and
and she came up and looked at my tattoo
in my back and she pulled down her sock
and said look my I can't see mine is
fading mine's fading there's a camera in
front of me I can't see it then Jason
said I have a tattoo on my dick
um Trish and I said yeah whatever and
turned away to ignore him then Jason
came up behind us and pulled his penis
out of his pants his thumb was covering
the head and all I saw was the shaft
Trish and I turned away and went and
told
Tammy or Terry
some something damn somebody I was
standing at the Shack Bar because Jason
was harassing Nora
since we came in they were really
strange all night I think was maybe Lobo
was with him at the time yeah oh there's
more yeah I think like Lauren bobert was
like with him while he was flashing
these uh right and so what surprised me
about him that I never really realized
is
this accounts of it she was approached
by Lauren bobert first and like what it
says yeah it's she came up and said
something about her tattoo and then
showed her her tattoo
and then I guess the husband was there
too does this not sound like they were
like grooming together yeah does it not
sound like they were like together yeah
and they say at the end they were being
really strange all night like I always
just thought there was like an argument
or something and or whatever and he
whipped his dick out but like this
sounds like they were kind of
approaching these young girls together
anyway she is so [__] vile another
phony who talks about family values who
is like basically a groomer with her
husband or this is him wow
wow
what a [__] I'd like to see bro what
Jesus what compels guys like this to
spike their hair
that's what I want to know because like
you're making yourself look more bald
brother what the [__] is that that's
true you see the more dumb that way for
like listen listen that [__] was like I
guess that [__] was a jam in like 2003
okay any point past that if you're like
above the age of 12 little girls you
want to see my dick tattoo
God damn sorry
go ahead sorry oh my gosh got a holster
too Jesus Christ hey little girl is
everybody gather round check out my dick
tattoo Rifle Colorado brother just how
we do it hey don't lock him young would
you take a seat right over there 16 is
the perfect age I tell you what
anyway this is a rising star or well
she's Rich her star has risen this is
Lauren bobert Lobo a huge uh almost got
[__] owned by some random dude in her
own district for the record like that
but she still won she barely squeezed
that Victory out but uh two people
watching again I will remind you this is
the conservative party
Lauren bober
Steven Crowder Blair white he's [__]
scumbags are soulless they care about
nothing but power and money and clout
and they will uh throw anyone under the
bus the thing is so do the Democratic
party right like so do the Democrats uh
in positions of power but at least
they're not doing it in the same [__]
way that these freaks are doing it
they're not as bad I'm sorry yeah the
Democrats there's really [__]
horrifying demons on there too like
Henry Cuellar Bob Menendez you know all
of the uh all the classic like Centrist
Democrats that uh play the role of like
a rotating villain in the in the uh in
the Democratic party to stop any kind of
progressive legislation from ever
passing like [__] those guys they're
[__] demons I hate them but having
said that for the the broad majority of
the democratic party at least like
aesthetically don't uh run around and do
these like culture War things that they
don't necessarily believe in in the same
way that like Lauren bobert does you
know what I mean at least they're
advocating for stuff that actually will
help people at least a little bit well
they're doing it aesthetically
specifically so that they can like
capture a a you know a base of Voters
what noise was he making he was growling
at Sam because she just came in
um so anyway a condolences to Lauren on
losing that fine specimen of a sex
offender
we love that for him but that's a good
segue let's see into um
uh Diane's not in a box yet
uh and boy this is a real [__] [__]
show the Democrats are such cowards this
woman is almost 90 years old she's had
dementia for probably five years
and uh she when she arrived back
in Congress
someone was like uh what's it like being
away for so long she's like I haven't
been away yeah I've been I've been here
the whole time she's doing great yeah
she said those who know no and those who
don't don't know or something like that
and then they wheeled her off of course
you can say more incriminating [__] why
are they so intent on keeping her
why are they doing this to her
there's a there's a very plausible
theory that uh came out uh just this
morning that uh
that we're going to get to in a minute
like dude she's not fit to play Bingo
let alone run our [__] country you
know what I mean it's like like if you
think if you think she's fit if you
think she's mentally fit to be in such a
powerful committee like part of the part
of the only power that the legislative
body has at this point is appointments
like Court appointments and also
investigations into I don't know the
Supreme Court for example which
currently is under a lot of [__]
reasonable scrutiny for the first time
in its goddamn history since his [__]
Inception with Clarence Thomas and His
like Financial misdeeds and uh his
refusal overall to uh you know write
down
um lobbying dollars that he's gotten
from people
that actually have a lot of business
with the Supreme Court right like right
now you need uh the the Senate judicial
uh committee to launch investigation
she's she's a part of it I don't know if
she's the chair but I think she might be
the chair dude but the point is this
right they they do appointments they
vote for uh they they uh they're the
ones who are supposed to investigate the
the uh Judiciary put in judges
um yeah and they're not doing that
because they can't do that because one
of the uh you know more senior most
senior members on the [__] uh
committee is dead okay she's
functionally a vegetable that can move
around yeah she is the uh second behind
Dick Durbin yeah Dick Durbin who's also
also died yeah so Diana uh Diane has
missed 91 Senate votes
[Music]
welcome back Queen
Biden hasn't been able to get any
federal judges confirmed since her
absence and it was announced in February
they should be retiring at the end of
her term in 2024.
uh there have been calls for her to
resign nobody's nobody wants to do
anything about it
uh
Nancy Pelosi actually another old ass
[__]
freak by the way CR [__] Nancy Pelosi
dude and her husband scumbags [__]
them both dude she's of course she's
gonna say she's 80 herself like step
aside Grandma but she's like yo it's
sexist to ask uh for Feinstein to resign
I'm sorry
Senator Feinstein has been a champion
for Cal great move the [__] on
I dreamed I saw my maternal grandma oh
God
Jordan go on off Jordan continue okay so
region was explosions brother had the
appearance of a thick mat of hair
she was she said it all absent-mindedly
go on
so here's the over to me oh God it's a
handful of pubic hair compacted into
something resembling a large artist's
paintbrush she pushed this at my face
right I raised my arm several times to
deflect her hand finally unwilling to
hurt her or interfere with her any
further if I let her have her way thank
you there it is said it all
so Feinstein is a vote is genuinely
important for appointments uh for for
judges obviously because uh you know
it's the majority and all narrow
majority in the Senate and all
um but also they knew
they knew that she was like brain dead
for uh years now they've correctly
pointed out there was always talk you
know there's always like a political
article here and there that like talked
about whether she was capable or not
um when they were doing the the
Kavanaugh confirmation uh she had a lot
of like weird takes that uh and she had
to be like the room and stuff like this
is the best run Committee of all time or
I forget what she said and you want to
know what you want to know you want to
know what's [__] awful about all that
they knew all of that and then they
still put her on the [__] Judiciary
Committee yeah they still put her on so
the Democrats are [__] responsible
why do they do it because well this may
not be why but all the head senior high
level Democrats are all like 75 plus old
[__] who don't want to be uh
who don't want to retire no it's the
same it's that but also there's a
secondary reason and that reason is what
I just mentioned to you already Maggie
Hassan Kirsten Cinema who's now
independent Joe manchin uh Bob Menendez
these people in the Democratic Party
play a very important role a much more
important role than the the aocs and the
Bernie Sanders is and even the Ed
markies of the democratic party which
are more to the progressive side those
guys are bad the progressives are bad in
the eyes of the national Democratic
party the DNC the the the the the people
who hold the levers of power they look
to Progressive candidates and they look
to Progressive senators and and
representatives
as a a genuine threat to the established
order because the Democratic party does
not want to make the actual Progressive
changes that they campaign on so they
love when there's a bottleneck and
Dianne Feinstein's uh you know uh Dianne
Feinstein's mental faculties not being
in order and her inability to actually
do the job that she was elected for is
actually not that bad of a thing for the
Democratic party because they can always
point to her and go oh [__] we really
wanted to do this thing
but we can't start an investigation
Dianne Feinstein's not there you think
so I think that plays a role yes I think
that because it's not an accident that
every election cycle they're like oh we
need the majority we need a majority in
the Senate we need a majority in the
representative House of Representatives
uh you know we need to win and then
immediately they create bottlenecks for
themselves uh that that stand in the way
of progressive legislation that they
promised like 15 minimum wage was a was
a promise right increasing minimum wage
at the federal level to 15 is a promise
uh that was not fulfilled why wasn't it
fulfilled because
they pointed to the Senate
parliamentarian claiming that uh
increasing the minimum wage of fifteen
dollars would not actually fit under the
jurisdiction of a a budget
reconciliation bill
which it absolutely would for the record
but the Senate parliamentarian claimed
that it would not work you could not put
that in and the Democratic party just
basically threw their hands at the side
and went oh [__] we can't do that not
the Parliamentary not the same thing
that we all know what it is and the
Senate parliamentarian is a historically
appointed position and actually the
Senate parliamentarian has been removed
in the past by Republicans under the
Bush Administration anytime a senate
parliamentarian says no you have uh well
within your power to actually remove
them from power and appoint someone who
will play ball with you that is of
course if you genuinely care about
following through on your agenda which
the Democrats don't so Dianne
Feinstein's ineptitude here her medical
inability to to you know do the job is
actually not a burden it's a burden to
you if you are a you know doughy-eyed uh
believer in the Democratic party them to
be ineffective
that they're gonna do something and then
they don't get it done okay it's not
going to help any of them no let me
explain the Democratic party loves
winning seats but also still losing
power somehow why because the Democratic
party just like the Republican Party are
beholden to the same corporate interests
those are the guys who are greasing
their wheels the same corporations and
the same wealthy people are the people
that are giving them money just like
they're giving the Republican Party
money the Republican party also on the
other hand can play a culture War issue
uh focused uh policy uh policy strategy
and win votes the Democratic party on
the other hand has to put on uh economic
progress as like one of their key agenda
items right but they don't actually want
to follow through on that because every
single thing that they would do whether
it be increasing the minimum wage
fifteen dollars or abolishing all
student loan debt for example would hurt
a lot of their real benefactors their
real constituents that they care about
corporations in the mega wealthy so they
have to constantly and it's not an
accident if you've been following
Politics as long as I have we've been
covering this for as long as I have
after like the 10th cycle of oh [__] we
really can't do this again because Joe
Lieberman is standing in the uh you know
way of progress under the Obama
Administration when we have a super
majority in the senate or oh [__] Joe
manchin and Kirsten Cinema are standing
in the way of progress and we can't
actually get all of our uh you know
policy items on to
a bill that we should be able to
effectively spear dick through Congress
uh you realize that they're doing that
on purpose they're doing that because it
is by Design they do not want the
legitimate material change to happen
because that would undermine profit
margins
sorry it's been a while since I've been
here I'm just [__] talking to me
interesting and it's sad
Nancy Pelosi I mean again her insider
trading with her husband is so blatant
it actually makes me want to puke he's
like the most successful Trader of all
time
uh but anyway here she is we didn't we
never even got to her saying
for 20 years I have been the leader or
the Speaker of the House fighting for
California and I have seen up close and
firsthand her great leadership oh have
you seen up close in firsthand her
dementia her demented mind okay here's
what I got wait hold on hold on hold on
let's finish the video okay yeah
but especially for our state of
California uh she deserves the respect
to to get well and be back suck my
[__] [__] [__] you I mean she could
get well
[__] monster you donkey shut up most
[__] animal I mean most people taking
the time to get well is like you know
retiring I mean at that age yes enjoy
the fruits of Life get the [__] out of
here
no she [__] doesn't no she doesn't
leave Japan I hate you you're not you do
not deserve the the wonderful public
transit experience that Japan offers to
every single person until we get the
high-speed rail in California I'm
waiting for the she's about to drop the
bond she's dropping the ball right
essentially
it's interesting that's not true they
did this to Pryor they did this to Briar
we literally did this to Briar Briar
retire and it worked look at her face
and it [__] worked look at this
[__] face here's what I gotta say you
want Feinstein to be in the Senate great
okay you [__] Advocate that in public
you have to let her drive you to [__]
Congress every morning
she has the mental faculty driver drive
the car to Congress okay let her drive
you to [__] Congress absolutely she's
not fit to serve soup at a soup kitchen
I mean she can't do she probably can't
even dress herself let's be real I don't
think this woman dresses herself no
she's done she's over it's literally a
shell okay it's the [__] the you know
the lights on in the Attic but nobody's
uh home or whatever they say yeah okay
thank you uh to uh Nancy Pelosi who's a
vile piece of crap and also demon dude
yo it's so funny that like people that
you would not oh wait you would not
trust to to man a [__] vehicle that
you're inside of for understandable
reasons are are still trustworthy
somehow to man the [__] country man
and it goes to show you like
it it's true like they don't really care
who is in that seat it's just an ass and
a seat okay and the irony is there are
plenty of [__] old ass Senators old
as Representatives who should retire but
won't but ultimately at least they can
sit on that seat and vote Dianne
Feinstein can't even [__] do that
when there's a narrow there is a slim
majority in the in the Senate there is
an interesting Wrinkle in this
uh Nance uh Diane's primary caregiver is
Nancy Pelosi's daughter
yeah this uh this is from an article
that just came out this morning oh my
God yeah that makes so much sense uh
here it says holy [__] what a bombshell
well let me read this and then you can
go pee all right
I can't get through a single guy
you can't hear me this is this is
important Hassan you need to be here for
this here I'll figure it out I'll read
I'll read the donos in the meantime we
got a bunch uh somebody said they just
spent 500 on the new Teddy fresh straw
oh [__] I forgot that let's shout out
Colton yeah here use this uh short
commercial break
the new Classics Collection just dropped
uh this morning at 10 A.M is it not
loading or is that our internet there's
a website okay there it goes yeah so
here it is
I'm wearing the fruit neck right now
um right now
I am as well
so I'm gonna be showing you guys a
couple little years the bear ear uh
hoodie we got fuzzy beanies
hoodies
the women's classic fleece shorts are
coming soon
classic dad hat 20 bucks women shrunken
tea 20 bucks the women's uh zip up and
pants are coming soon
classic hoodie 60 bucks you know it's so
nice I'm telling you you get your hands
on one of these things
hot right now we said they spent two
thousand that's gotta be careful
thousand uh come on can you even spend
that much if you buy everything
two thousand I said I spent 2 000 dual
me holy [__] dude
I get it you message Luke and see if he
can see if someone actually spent two oh
we're gonna call you out we're gonna
call you out I'm not gonna dox you I
just want to know if that actually
happened look the classic zip up Hoodie
which is Iconic I think the zip up
Hoodie is coming back in a big way slim
fitting sweatpants we got socks we got
the bear ear hoodie I mean this is
usually 95 when we do it like in the
regular way it's 86 wow
yesterday 22 bucks Man classic beanie 20
bucks
we got the ears zip up we also have a
long sleeve uh pocket tee Polo 25 bucks
20 bucks man it's crazy the deals are
insane I'm just so proud of this
collection we put together I'm so happy
wow you would look at this while I'm
gone so I can't [__] order everything
I see how it is I see what's going on
here and the classic crew which is 55
I'm so happy we're gonna be adding more
colors more Silhouettes but the classics
is here to stay and uh thank you guys
for trying it you're gonna love it you
want to pick some stuff it's just it's
really we made like a Classics
Collection yeah really nice
I mean I like you know what I like I
like that the those shorts the women's
oh God they're women's shorts we have
shorts they're short the women's shorts
are short here this one no but that's
not short that's long you want it
shorter than that yeah
I guess we can make short shorts for it
yo I'm trying to show these quads man
we're [__] working hard you know what
I mean it's the summer you can hike them
up bad boys [__] possible off I want
the socks though for sure I want all the
socks there's uh tube socks and oh I
guess there's three uh two packs of tube
sauce
all right someone writing that down yeah
thank you the tube socks for Hassan all
right
thank you
you know the guy love yeah I can confirm
that he spent that much oh there you go
what the hell so hard he's a massive who
are you
oh here's the here's Diane Dianne
Feinstein she's so trusted she operates
heavy machinery wait is that is that
what happened to Jeff I thought David
oh man [__] no wonder no she's cool man
she she's she's all good don't worry
okay I trust her to operate that
me too okay so about uh so her primary
caregiver is Nancy Pelosi's daughter
okay Nancy wait her her daughter's name
is Nancy too sure is arrogant a little
bit she's Nancy the second maybe even
the third I don't know Nancy Pelosi
named her own daughter Nancy that's kind
of psychotic Nancy Pelosi's daughter
famously works
Nancy Pelosi's daughter is like famous
for saying some of y'all's faves are
about to be implicated uh who has a
different daughter but yes I know what
you're talking about
uh with uh so let me let me read this by
all accounts the arrangement is rooted
in a long and friendly relationship
between Feinstein and Pelosi but among
some of those who are aware it also
raised uncomfortable questions about
whether Nancy Pelosi's political
interests are in conflict with
Feinstein's personal interest the
Intrigue surrounds the future of
Feinstein's seat Pelosi has endorsed rep
Adam Schiff her longtime Protege and
former hand-picked house intelligence
committee chair to six to see succeed
Feinstein after her sixth and final term
ends next year Schiff is a household
name in California and already has a 50
million dollar campaign cash advance
over his next competitor but a Feinstein
were to bow out now and retire shift's
Advantage would disappear Governor Gavin
Newsom has pledged to appoint a black
woman to serve out her term and one of
schiff's declared opponents Barbara Lee
would foot that bill that explains it
yeah [__] which is weird because Gavin
Newsom is like a party man right
um he is a he is a an Institutional
Democrat so it's rather odd but I guess
he made that play you make a promise
well first of all I I personally [__]
despise when Democrats say that because
it's like Barbara Lee would be fine in
that position on her own she has the
Bona fides you don't need to be like Oh
I'm appointing a black woman I agree
it's the same with like katanji brown
Jack that very odd yeah it's it's so
weird well it's like well you're taking
the dub away from her too because it's
like let's just pick the best person
yeah who happens to be black yeah it's
like there are plenty of qualified uh
black women in that to to be uh well
hold on what about um Andrew Cuomo I am
black oh I hear he's available actually
oh no he's a black woman I heard oh yeah
he's gay too and a Muslim I am a Muslim
I am disabled right oh he's yeah so he's
hits a lot of the boxes yeah that
explains so her own selfish desire to
serve her protege
this has got to be it this has to be it
I know the whole time we've been
wondering and then just this morning saw
that this article came out and all of a
sudden it's all clicked that's [__]
and that's so gross a lot of people
thought it was interesting that rokana
uh was one of the only people that were
calling for her to resign rocana is
Barbara Lee's uh campaign chair yeah
rokana is it interesting it's all it's
all it's all maneuvering it's all yeah
it is so pathetic the consequence of
their stupid [__] game they're
literally doing Weekend at Bernie's like
I know that's obvious and funny and haha
that's literally what Nancy Pelosi is
doing her daughter is there being her
primary caretaker this is psychotic this
is elder abuse I'm gonna straight I
think it's elder abuse a little bit yeah
you know
thank you
[Applause]
so much
and everybody else Kyle Mart Pizza Time
thank you guys
so uh that's the story you want to do
Rudy Giuliani or Elon entering as
Neo-Nazi era I can I can do both I mean
I don't really care whatever we have
time for whatever you want to do I like
both of those stories let's start with I
hope to hit both of them let's just uh
let's do Elon entering his Neo-Nazi era
you're a bunch of [__] a shut up Rudy
I'll do yours if you want me to let's do
Rudy's then [__] you Rudy you guys in
October yes so this one's actually kind
of fasted shut up Rudy
excuse the expression I will not be
excusing the expression no yeah but
sexual dance you'd be so rude really
stop I don't know that's it for you Rudy
Rudy giuliani's former aide Noella
Dunphy is suing him for sexual
harassment while she worked for him
between 2019 and 2 20 uh 2020. the
[__] in this complaint
is pretty inflammatory disgusting the
70-page suit claims among uh that he
made her work naked he made her perform
oral sex he drank all day and night made
racist remarks sexist remarks made
anti-semit anti-semitic marks didn't pay
his bills here's the one
that is really uh [__] interesting it
claims that
Rudy said that him and Trump were were
selling pardons for two million dollars
a pop yeah you know what's really
interesting about the story and I'll say
one more thing
well she has apparently a ton of
recordings and receipts this isn't just
yeah this isn't just her saying this
[__] she's she has receipts on this [__]
the the sale of the pardon side of this
story like the the sexual assault sexual
harassment that was like rampant is uh
pretty pretty basic like very
commonplace in Republican circles in
politics in general uh it's inexcusable
it's gross but what's actually uh a
little bit different uh is the the uh
the pardon sales scheme that uh Rudy
Giuliani allegedly was engaged in now
what I find interesting about that
is that this is not the first time that
this has ever been mentioned as a matter
of fact there was a it was a CIA
whistleblower under the Obama
Administration that uh that was you know
that went to jail for two years uh and
and he was one of the people that um
originally went to Rudy Giuliani and uh
hired a republican lobbyist and went to
Rudy Giuliani uh to potentially get a
pardon from Donald Trump and um he this
experience was actually uh uh covered in
the New York Times two years ago so what
I find really interesting about it is
that like there has already been stuff
out there yeah and they never really
investigated it any further which I find
very stunning because it would be so
easy to tell if this happened you could
easily follow you can look at who was
pardoned yeah and follow the money and
follow the connections of each one and
find out why each one was pardoned you
could [__] easily investigate this
and find out well there could also have
been an attempt potentially and not
necessarily follow through on it so that
that's something to also keep in mind
um so and it's still an attempt to uh an
attempt to do this is still illegal so
this was the legend yeah yeah the CIA
whistleblower uh linked up with them met
up with them had a conversation wow uh
oh he said the two million number two
yep so they somehow knew the same exact
number that is interesting this was
publicly known so yeah you could maybe
argue that she was just referencing this
okay well she has I mean I believe her
so I don't know what if she has receipts
on this one well that's the argument
they will probably make yeah so the the
only new component of this story that
she's alleging is that there was a there
was a scheme to
uh divide the fee 50 50 1 million for
Trump one million for Rudy that's
actually new information and uh that's
the new thing that they're alleging
pretty generous cut for Rudy uh yeah
well he's the one who's facilitating it
well technically according to the CI
whistleblower he went to lunch with Rudy
yeah and he said okay so let's talk
about this part and and Rudy immediately
got up and left the table
and then his uh Aid that was at the
table was like you talk to me about this
stuff Mafia also [__] yeah
rackets which is weird like you're a
prosecutor how do you [__] not know
that like
Rudy Giuliani is most notorious for
[__] using Rico charges as a
prosecutor in New York right in the
[__] mayor against the mob right but
you know that that doesn't [__]
absolve you you [__] idiot although
he guess you know well he's not very
bright is he you think Trump is
regretting this uh Giuliani uh
Association yet no I don't think so
because you think they're best friends
has always uh surrounded himself with
people exactly like Rudy Giuliani just
like
not people necessarily that he's hired
because they're the best at their job
for people who knows will also con at
his behest well so this this uh
secretary was apparently hired according
to her for off the book sexual favors he
owes her apparently like uh two million
dollars that he never paid her he was
paying her a million dollar a year
salary
then anyone could be paid to suck Rudy
giuliani's disgusting uh sexual among
the things that she apparently has
recorded potentially allegedly
is him saying black guys hit women more
than anyone else so do Hispanic guys
it's in their culture as he as he forced
this woman to suck his dick right yeah
uh dumfry claimed that Giuliani mocked
Jews over Passover Jews just want to go
through their freaking Passover all the
time man oh man get over the Passover it
was like 3 000 years ago the Red Sea
parted big deal that's not the first
that's kind of a good bit
I mean you could be honest when you're
well because you're you're a New Yorker
when you're a New Yorker you got that I
feel like that's the type of thing like
a Jewish comedian would say I agree same
with like Donald Trump like he has like
that Sassy you know he he has that Sassy
George Costanza energy sometimes like
this I feel like is similar to that well
then he also said allegedly that Jews
penises are inferior due to Natural
Selection
okay that okay that's not very Larry
David I don't I don't know what the [__]
that even means that's just weird man
what the [__] the election yeah uh she
claims Rudy knew that the 2020 election
was a fraud and intentionally lied about
it while surprised
she continued to perform the work
claimed that Giuliani callously tossed
her aside never paid her and left her
traumatized by the abuse she had
suffered uh fantastic
uh what a guy huh so okay that's
Giuliani uh the most vile disgusting
person probably ever walked this Earth
the penguin he's one of them
and when he ejaculates it's not semen
it's just tonsil stones oh God not with
the tonsils I just can't I I can't get
the image of Rudy giuliani's disgusting
hair dye that's what I was leaking every
time I think about Rudy Juliana
here's a fun here's a fun little thing
uh from the core proceedings like from
the court documents they actually
pointed to the Sasha Baron Cohen yeah uh
Borat subsequent movie yeah uh scene
where Rudy Giuliani knowingly tries to
have sexual intercourse yes with a with
a minor spot on on camera not knowing
that there's a camera there obviously so
they actually pointed to that and said
this is exactly what he did to me 100
man yeah and he touches his dick no no
he was adjusting his pants oh excuse me
excuse me yeah yeah yeah that's what he
was doing that's how you adjust your
pants yeah I was taking my my dick out
and then I never understood that because
it even if that was true here here he
still went to a hotel room with a miner
right like like that part is in dispute
just to talk shop though well they were
doing an interview see yeah it's so
funny and well they were gonna do it
in the movie she was meant to be
underage I think in the movie she was in
real life no actress wasn't under it was
she I didn't know that I think she was
supposed to be 50. yeah no she's 24. she
said supposed to be 15. yeah she says
holy [__] multiple times that she's
underage yeah and Rudy's aware of it in
the scene what's insane to me is that
um he is the biggest idiot in the world
man like this is this is literally EDP
[__] you know what I mean this is like
Chris Hansen like Whatever Whenever like
a pedophile gets caught right on camera
and Chris Hansen comes over like we'll
just take a seat like they're always
like oh I was just here
adjusting my pants
how does that work for Rudy when it
doesn't work for like every other
[__] uh pedophile uh Schmo that has
tried to do the same thing I was just
getting a cupcake what was on the agenda
tonight
classic such a classic [__] bit to be
like oh I was just here for cupcakes
actually just the saddest looking
situation I mean what the [__] bro
that would be the saddest [__]
[__] that ever took place on this
Earth his flaccid penis like oh no he
can't get it up oh no you know he's got
no Viagra you know the Viagra is not
cancer actually that's alleged in the in
his dick so lost no that he he's like a
cereal he's popular Viagra like all day
every day yeah that's right and he would
talk about how like do something about
my boner
so he takes Viagra like a daily
supplement popping him like candy like
[__] breasts good for my heart Ethan
I'm sure come on
all right let's move so we might
actually have time to hit everything now
let's do elon's uh
uh oh my God okay this is important
what Elon klansman no no this what do
you think of this
I don't know I don't know what it means
but it means something this is okay
these are Horrors Beyond human uh
imagination I never I never thought take
it in brother
feel it horrific the conservative
movement is popping man these are some
of your Heroes guys good job you're
[__] doing it
um
so okay elon's in his Nazi so Elon Musk
has pretty much gone full mask off this
week uh it's been pretty heavy duty very
and and to be honest quite disturbing
that the richest one of the most
powerful people in the world is just
actually like a white supremacist
um
well
a lot of them are so you know
I guess it's uh but the main difference
is that he's like
he's not like an old guy racist he's
like a internet grouper racist you know
what I mean uh which is which is way
more annoying that's worse yeah because
old people are just like dumb and
ignorant racist yeah rapers are like we
hate Jews because yeah we are just we're
just like Nazis yeah and obviously
there's like a couple steps in between
those and and it is significant uh where
you stand ideologically because like it
also means like you know it's it's a
path for
Rehabilitation and I feel like when you
get to the Elon Musk point it's just
like I don't think I mean he's so
narcissistic surrounded himself with the
s-men and sycophants and a legion of
like sycophant stands that are some of
the dumbest people on the planet that
are also like financially invested in
his success as well because they have
the Tesla stock and [__] so or at least
they think that they're financially
invested in his success
so so it's impossible to turn him around
on this stuff he is also so horny like
the red-headed he wants to [__] this uh
lady so bad dude the redheaded
libertarian he is her he is her reply
guy he is her moment I'll tell you
something I'm not gonna say who told me
this but somebody I know
told me that actually I know she she
showed me the receipts he was cutting
her up in the DMS yeah yeah okay you
gotta tell me dude it was [__] juicy
gossip she I promise not to say anything
but like holy [__] it is very
embarrassing yeah no he is but he's like
openly posted about how he hasn't like
[__] in years or whatever like or not
[__] years but he was like oh God I
haven't had sex in so long like he
posted that [__] when he was like 47.
yeah but that's not really probably true
is it
I mean I don't know but like it's it's a
wild thing to post you're not like a
[__] teenager uh with with no
following online you know what I mean
like that's weird that you're horny
posting like that all right so what
happened let's do the timeline so it
first started here during the uh I
started doing Allen Texas yeah the
shooting in Allen Texas where a white
supremacist a hispanic white supremacist
uh went to a mall and shot a bunch of
people
um and and uh the conservative movement
instead of doing the usual thoughts and
prayers song and dance that they do or
the whole like we're distancing
ourselves away from this white
supremacist uh shooter song and dance
that they do they decided to rush to
something that I haven't really seen in
a situation like this before I've seen
it in school shootings but never seen it
in like an out and about mass shooting
of a white supremacist because it was so
such a slam dunk like obvious like this
guy he's like watching Tim pool he's
watching all these people it's in his
but if the man has swastikas tattooed on
his body yeah and so they go this is so
such a slam dunk it's so obvious we
can't escape it therefore it's a Psy up
so the red-headed librarian who the [__]
that is this sounds like a psyop an
employee of state-funded media told us a
Jewish lady and a Korean guy
radicalized a Mexican Neo-Nazi gang
member Korean guys Tim Poole by the way
he is he's House Korean yeah Temple
South Korean uh he's the Korean guy it
shocked me for a second and the Jewish
lady is uh lives of tick tock
oh you didn't know this uh she's uh such
a vile is that is that is that the term
uh is it yeah yeah no yeah yeah I know
she is she is a uh piece of [__] yeah
she's a gross ass you didn't know that I
only [__] with I only [__] with uh
reformed Jews I'm not down with all that
right [__] up yeah it is I'm straight
up mathematic when it comes to anyone
who's not oh God don't say that don't
say that they're gonna use that against
you what the [__] I got I'm not a real
[__] I'm not supporting you can
literally say like bad Jews exist bad
juice bad juice bad juice
I'm a bad Jew I don't want to everybody
say stop telling me do everybody hate
you know how much anti-semitic comments
I get I says dude I don't care I'm not I
don't want to have I'm not I don't claim
this [__] just [__] leave me alone
you're not self-hating Jew I'm not
self-hating at all uh
uh or maybe a little bit but not because
of the Jewish people yeah yeah yeah
well that's what Ben would say about you
anyway um so so anyway so okay
pimples Korean guy yeah and and uh yeah
first of all nobody knows lives of tick
tock including yourself did not know
that Libs of tick tock is a is a Jewish
lady first of all so no I know that
because I'm a [__] freak but uh you
didn't even know that and you follow
lives of tick tock you're a big fan uh
yeah yeah we have a lot in common yeah
um radicalize the Mexican Neo-Nazi gang
member okay uh
according to a recent diary that
appeared on a Russian social media site
which wasn't even recent he's been
documenting it as a diary on this
Russian website to avoid scrutiny most
likely to like have uh you know to have
something like a Manifesto basically uh
untouched also yell simp for Russians
and like their culture the way that like
gay people don't exist in Russia yeah
the Russian social media site also is
like very popular it's ridiculous as
they're saying it's obscure it's obscure
to you but it's not an obscure website
anyway
did I happen to have received to the gun
used and the pictures of Nazis pulled
off Reddit and the internet
even though he doesn't speak Russian
wait where are you reading that
I'm right there oh here here God yeah
keep going keep going so he posted
everything on there how he was going to
do it why he was going to do it how he
got radicalized day by day
he visited the site he visited the mall
a week before the shooting took photos
and um you don't need to speak Russian
to post on that website
and yes he would routinely post like
mood board [__] like a Pinterest of you
know eclectic esoteric Hispanic Nazis as
a matter of fact which do exist there
are plenty of Nazis in Latin American
countries if you didn't know that well
Welcome to the Real World they do exist
he was posting photos of them and saying
these are my people these are my people
um he did this over a course of like a
very long time too it's not like you can
fake that [__] you know what I mean
unless they were like I guess setting up
a [__] psyop and posting this dude's
like private information that they
somehow had access to including photos
from his phone that they posted like a
months in advance on this Russian
website
tattooed all over his [__] they they
also like SWAT yeah they also got him a
swastika tattoo they tattooed him with a
swastika I guess to do the psyop
and then uh you know he went and he shot
people at this mall so this take is
obviously insanely stupid but hold on it
gets signal boosted by Elon Musk the
owner of the website
uh didn't the story come from Belling uh
cat yeah bellingcat which liter
literally specializes in psychological
operations I don't want to hurt their
feelings but this is either the weirdest
story ever or a very bad psyop it's not
that weird of a story
a Neo-Nazi shot people it's archetypes
really pretty straightforward yeah
that's pretty hard for the course there
yeah so why is he this is psychotic to
be signal boosting
that this Mass shooter who is a this man
he's like I'm a white supremacist please
everybody I want you to know I'm a Nazi
and they're like okay he's like please
I'm doing this for you guys they're like
I need to mention something here
first and foremost I'm gonna defend Elon
Musk
I'm gonna do it
number one your honor he was really
horny
you think he just wanted to [__] he had
him yeah you know that red-headed
libertarian got him acting strange okay
on the timeline he he is such a [__]
pathetic little sweaty reply guy like he
replies that everything that she posts
first of all I'm not familiar with her I
I don't know anything about her either
but every time he [__] replies to her
it's like all over your your for you
page
so yeah
so that's number one number one your
honor he's very horny okay number two
he's not wrong bellingcat is a CIA
backed uh uh operation that is true that
does not mean that everything that
bellingcat does uh is uh at the behest
of the CIA or a uh psychological
operation uh Belling cat also does have
some you know great reporters great
journalists they are an open source
intelligence uh uh investigative team
for the most part it's all reporting on
this though what
they did the sole reporting on this no
yeah it's not them only also they were
just the ones that dug up that social
media yeah no the New York Times is the
one who originally broke it which by the
way uh again you could make the same
argument about the New York Times They
Work hand in hand with the state
department and intelligence communities
let's be [__] real
um but
the New York Times originally said that
this dude had like they they found the
they found his account uh but
guess what
like the cops also said as soon as they
saw this dude that maybe there was
uh possibly a uh hate crime motive here
and cops are notorious for never jumping
the gun in that regard right parse you
know partially because like they are
also racist themselves as an institution
and individually so when you have cops
go yeah this might be a hate crime
that's how you know that's how you know
that it very likely is a [__] hate
crime uh Ian miles Chung who if you know
him you know what he's about the lead
Shooters alleged profile claims that he
was inspired by Libs of tick tock
between this and Temple references this
thing is suspect where is his Twitter
account why was he using Russian social
media site to write and essentially a
diary to zero followers redhead
librarian says it's a psyop and it's not
even good and then Elon of course like
you said I do think he's horny posting
you're right then he goes it's gets
weirder by the moment it's the same it
hasn't gotten weirder if this is a psyop
it's not even good is so stupid because
if this is a psyop it's literally the
best psyop ever that means that anyone
and everyone could technically
completely be like robbed of their own
genuine identity and be turned into like
a white supremacist Mass shooter because
this guy was so genuinely that right
that it's impossible to like fake this
media profile especially because the the
Russian
website that they're referencing had a
username that linked back to the [__]
Mass shooter and his YouTube which we
also looked through which uh actually
had a face reveal and it was his [__]
face and it wasn't like recent either
you know what I mean so how the [__] did
they do this it was this like a
year-long two-year-long operation it's
weirder by the moment dude yeah so what
is wild about this is also what is the
purpose of this psyop is it to what tell
us that [__] white supremacists are
bad you really need a [__] psyop to
know that do you think the the federal
government the the intelligent
communities are like guys we got to do
something about this now
it's like an anti-semitic thing where
it's like P there's the Jews are trying
to drum up sympathy I I don't know no
sorry app is a real thing to the
military engages I know but their their
theory behind it seems anti-Semitic
this guy up I mean I don't know what
we're talking about or or like
I mean the one that they always do is
like they're doing these mass shootings
to take away our guns yeah there's not
even a push to do that and it's doesn't
nothing ever it doesn't work
literally literally
hordes of children Dude down in their
schools 200 plus mass shootings and it's
not happening yeah like it's gonna
happen yeah yeah what a psyop dude yeah
they just keep failing I guess because
Americans are so good at avoiding psyops
uh Tim Poole who was a favorite of the
mass shooter
uh on the realization has this
incredible reflective moment yeah pause
it for a second before we get started
Tim pool originally was like this is a
sign up this is a psyop and then he when
faced with the reality they're like oh
no like this guy's like literally
[__] watching a bunch of his videos
and stuff it was like in his favorites
on his YouTube page from a long [__]
time ago this is his realization which
makes it even funnier because like he he
he no longer even deflects at this point
here's Tim pool on deep reflections
the tragic story coming out of Texas a
mass shooting and leftist researchers in
the corporate press are running with
this story that they've discovered the
profile of this individual and lo this
Mexican man is actually a white
supremacist why do they say that like
that matters like is it because they're
not that [__] they just they assume
Their audience doesn't realize there's
people that hate [__] Jews and
whatever you know what I mean like yeah
the bar to entry is pretty low two
reasons because it's like a very easy
own if you're a [__] dumbass like
dumbasses literally go but yeah right a
white supremacist Mexican one yes as you
correctly pointed out there are white
Mexicans out there uh there are plenty
of white Hispanics out there true two
doesn't even matter you could be a
[__] Brown Mexican person and still
be a white supremacist and there are
plenty of those as well you know it's a
it's a club that they're they
like I said the bar is very low they're
accepting members I think that guy's
post the shooter's post about Libs of
tick tock is like Illuminating in my
opinion it's like perfectly
representative of how fascist momentum
works right he doesn't know that she's
Jewish he doesn't give a he doesn't even
give a [__] he just likes the
transphobia that's why he's like oh Libs
of tick tock I love you you know what I
mean he doesn't care these guys don't
care they're just in it for the hatred
they're in it for the [__] violence
they're in it for the ethnic cleansing
they're in it for the feelings of
superiority in an otherwise like
powerless existence that they feel uh
burdened by yeah why do they sense to
like regain control by doing something
so chaotic why do they act like there's
no white Mexicans I find that's so
bizarre you're a white Korean you know
what I mean and you're a white
supremacist the [__] are you talking
about like yeah do you how do you feel I
I'd love to ask him how he feels being
referenced as a Korean man
oh he loves that are you kidding me he
loves saying that he's like oh I'm
Korean um how much Korean Tim I'm Korean
and anti-asian hate crimes uh are uh not
real unless we're talking about black
people doing them in which case I will
do racial agitation and say it's very
real
so much for the tolerant left you guys
are [__] on me Tim pool for being
bald how Korean is this man I mean that
doesn't matter there's no reason
bro like it's fine yeah I think he's
half Korean half
it could be
um maybe you can see on Wikipedia
referred to as korean-american
that's that's the whitest ass looking
[__] just like I'm [__] white
passing you know I'm white white passing
[__] yeah he is white just like I'm
white like I would
I would never consider Temple to be
anything but white
it's individual and low this Mexican man
is actually a white supremacist now the
thing is it seems like researchers have
uh dug through this profile it does not
seem to be real this person was posting
weird things in the past couple of weeks
to no followers and to No One not
because of course
right Vermont with it in this there are
on this profile there are posts about
Libs of tick tock and I believe it's
four clips from this show from one
particular episode that was enough I
think he thinks it's cool that people
are talking about him that he was
watching he did he posted about how oh
I'm trending again like it's great I
think he's he gets a kick out of it I
really don't know to distract away from
the trans shooter in in uh
at the like the premise is so funny
there's a shooting every day we don't
need to fake them
yeah I know it's it's so weird like the
most common thing in America come out
and yeah now Tim pool is trending and
claim that this individual was a fan of
this show I'm gonna come up outright and
just be like you're Liars that's not the
case you you you cannot imagine that he
watched your show
like you can't even stretch your uh
imagination that far yo Tim's using the
same mic stand at us did we like I have
the same with the podcast wait
how long have you guys been using this
for six years oh never mind dude we Dan
had to do like deep research to find
yeah it was like a brand new products
it's literally the best it's the best of
the best no no everybody was using these
big ones and was covering our face and I
was like what the [__] you know who I
got this from Bill uh Cody and Noel
because I was I had an exact issue and I
was like where the [__] did you get
these mic stands they're so sick dude
everybody said the history we saw the
History Podcast had these and we were
like damn he did not say that yeah he
well I I mean I have a conversation but
he said he thinks he said he invented
them he thanked us you don't get to say
someone posted a clip one time and
you're a fan because by that metric
Media Matters is our biggest fan shout
out to Media Matters for being huge fans
pause it for a second I got this clip
for Media Matters so shout out so here's
the difference here's the difference uh
the shooter's ideology aligns with you
that's the difference right he wasn't
criticizing you
who's gonna be comfortable
it's time to get canceled
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
if you want
not only not only did you hit the button
for the goofiest thing on the planet
you're just
a slur now yeah well you try I mean if
you want to talk about what really
happened let's just get down to it okay
well there was a there was a what on
this frame could Ethan have responded to
I think
about Goofy and confusing
perhaps the country flags I'm trying to
listen to this clip perhaps the country
flag that he got wrong maybe I don't
know maybe this guy looks like he's
trying to make a really important Point
[Laughter]
yeah the clip you could say what
happened I don't care it was a joke
oh he's got an Italian flag in the
background there and we're like no
that's not Italian and he immediately
slammed yeah
why not dude
to be fair this is excusable because you
know I I'm always on board with some
italiophobia you know what I mean yeah
thank you yeah subscribe to the channel
wow right like he's a fan like he wasn't
even subscribed it was it was uh four
clips from one show it wasn't a real
point is this is grasping at straws
right because even if they can
definitively prove even if it turns out
that this is legitimate that really is
this well hold on was it just one
episode he watched or uh he watched a
bunch of different episodes it was like
I think he had like an interview with
like Nick Fuentes and like just pearly
things and he watched a bunch of those
um I mean he watched like Abba and was
Abbott and preacher
watched them a lot he watched a video of
of them [__] on me actually no no no
it's peaches and cream peaches and cream
okay well yeah what do you think of that
nickname for ab and preach Peach peaches
and cream because they're not an honest
reaction I I have no opinion on those
guys because every time I've talked
about them they've cut like so many
videos giant pieces of [__] I yeah
they're [__] and they're I think
they're like um their lunches and cream
they're so they can sometimes be like
agreeable but I think that's why it's
like kind of Insidious where they're
soft they'll they'll come across like
reasonable at certain points and I'm
sorry y'all see something so unhinged
I'm like what the [__] no I'm sorry
y'all guys get in front of the camera
and talk like you're preaching dude you
guys are soft they take [__] out of
context or try to like quote unquote
dong okay but all of that aside
okay I think I think it demasculates
them and that's why I like it uh the
other one we have for them is not too
much about them I just heard like uh uh
one of the one of the dudes on there
like [__] as a own uh gave like 10
grand to the Atlanta Police Department
even though he's like Canadian which is
the most cuck thing you can do yeah like
FD signifier uh which one was it
so the other nickname for them we had
was uh Babble and reach way better right
what what even that's not that good oh
come on Babylon reach is pretty good I
need to I need to watch more of them
because the one dude babbles and the
other dude reaches
I'm gonna say this I will never I will
never forget when they made like
multiple videos about me saying like I'm
a [__] dumbass for calling them
transphobic potentially because I didn't
even say that they were like outright
trans people I was like oh this just
seems like transphobic uh [__] I don't
want to watch this video and then they
made like videos on it
they do the same thing to me dude yeah
they they made videos on it and in the
video they subsequently literally said
transphobic [__]
and everyone in the comments was like
yeah you're right this guy's such an
idiot you guys aren't transphobic [__]
trash people
um oh wait what is this they posted this
but I'm confused yeah they post that oh
they're oh they look so they like it
wait no they're apple and Pete yeah you
didn't say apple and Peach no they're no
you guys got it wrong he's actually is
like not bad yeah that's better than
people no no no no it's not he's just a
cream it's terrible I'm sorry they're
soft they're like a sweet bulldog
I just I don't know apple and Peach
that's not good at all I don't get that
so they did they took a clip from my
interview with Sebastian that like
dumbass Alpha dude completely owned
and they took a clip
and made it entitled like Ethan Klein's
embarrassing where they tried to make it
seem like Sebastian owned me yeah they I
was like what yeah no they do that you
do that all the time I'm willing to bet
that that video did numbers too of
course yeah they do that all the time
they're like they know that they're like
uh there's a lot of uh there's a market
for people that will [__] on you there's
Margaret of [__] on me here's the thing
about having content so they like kind
of take advantage of that a little bit
you know hey do your thing man make some
money
here's the thing it is here's the thing
about Abba and preach that they don't
know about me
they haven't uh they don't bother me
enough yet but I'll tell you this
I'm [__] insane
and if you and if you wanna if you want
to do the war thing that's my favorite
thing in the world and but I'm close
they're they're just they're they're
pathetic they're Liars they're dishonest
and they're phonies
they're not even genuine that's the
thing right here look at this here he
did uh you think cloud is embarrassing
and then Ethan Klein is mad at us
because they're insecure and hate me
because I'm fat I don't run but yeah I
mean look they they're like uh they're
like at the edge of the manosphere and
they make a lot of they used to like own
a lot of manosphere guys but then they
also have some like conservative points
of view they've they've cultivated a big
brand for themselves they came out
they're they're like not that this is
you know I mean you're comparing them to
like some of the worst people but like
they're I guess they're better than
fresh and fit and stuff for sure like
well
um no I'm just saying like they are more
agreeable like they are as far as I know
and their politics might have changed
but it seems like they're like you know
anti-overt white supremacy stuff like
that you know what I mean they they do
the thing on that I feel like they
become a gateway
I feel like they the first time they
talked about me was defending fresh and
fit
right it was so bizarre this girl called
in and was telling us about this
horrible date she had with the fit
and then they Def and then they make a
video saying how like she's a liar and
[__] I don't I didn't watch it today
I watched I watched some of it but it
was upsetting so I didn't watch it
they're centrists you know yeah yeah and
like and we know what that means kind of
um like I said I don't know enough about
them I just I have seen like although so
some of their commentary on like trans
issues and it just seemed like a you
know cookie cutter uh transphobic [__]
uh and it pops off you know there's
definitely a model it's definitely an
audience for it
um I think they they also loved when
like uh Gideon uh said that I was
implied that it was a pandering or I was
like oh no sorry I was uh
patronizing to him
but you know it is what it is do you but
I'm I'm down you guys you know what I
mean like I'm looking for my next uh
dragon you guys aren't a dragon though
you guys are like a gopher your channel
does well no their numbers are good but
their numbers are really good they know
they know the algo they know how to play
it no their their channel does really
good it's impressive the numbers they
pull to be honest I wish they weren't
but you're you're right in the way that
like I see them talking about like just
just pearly things like they they do
have like takes that I think are that's
why I said they have they have a lot of
like agreeable takes and then they have
like some where it's just like
is this any different than the people
that you're [__] on they literally
just throwing a bone to like
the people that hate us just because of
our politics yeah
it's no hanging fruit there's a market
for it yeah certainly and they're
they're capitalizing on it that's what
it is like it was so it was so
disingenuous when like
uh that's when I realized like that's
actually when I changed my policy of
like uh trying to genuinely respond
to people that would like cut videos of
me yeah like that yeah because I mean I
wouldn't do it because I wouldn't do it
if it was like a small Channel anyway
because like I'm not trying to like uh
you know boost their Audience by giving
them some of my [__] haters right
because there's always like hate
Watchers in there
um but uh they're uh they're a pretty
big Channel they yeah they have a big
following wait I was like I'll address
some of these takes and then I did and
then they like literally [__]
proved my point well simultaneously
saying that I was wrong they're one of
these people they operate in bad faith
and they'll just cut it and make a
million videos of it which is fun I
operating good faith enough that like
they have a lot of uh I'm saying like
they come across as as though they are
uh genuinely even keeled on a lot of
issues this is the thing I used to run
this problem with keemstar where no
matter what I said and did he would in
bad faith just come up over me and say
whatever and I found out the best way to
combat that in my case was to talk more
and I [__] love that game dude like
if I love it I I don't love it I like
you're way more combative I uh it's fun
but the thing is they're trying to
believe me alone
they probably will leave me alone that's
what Sebastian Sebastian hit it this is
their favorite guy who begged me alone
that's their Idol Sebastian by the way I
told them I was like why don't you guys
watch the whole video and then come tell
me how embarrassing I am let me think
about it hold on anyway can someone
watch this he has a video of him with
Rolo Tony Brown down
saying they're coming after us is he Pro
don't a brown town can you just preview
they're coming after us I want to see
that I would be genuinely shocked if
that were the case they're probably
making fun of him I hope so that would
be great the other part of this is that
like a lot of the people that they
feature in their commentary are
uh-oh people that like hold on you're
getting roasted here
if you play Hogwarts Legacy you're a
transphobe creators are afraid
what what I'm sure they did the classic
like actually you know what I don't know
they might have actually uh sided with
me on this and like uh hell no you think
so yeah they they do it they I think I'm
pretty sure they sometimes will like be
fair I don't know there's the most
replay the website where you can see all
the streamers who played the game so you
can unfollow or Target them I like that
they play Phil at two times speed that's
[__] everything yeah
don't be jealous
recently I picked yeah the game's fun to
play I'm gonna play the game man of
course the homeless guy says this bro
like you guys but they're loose he's
homeless
she's stupid that's one of the richest
creators I'm not stupid I don't know
this dude you got a whole this is like
he might he's smarter than coconuts I
won't put that on him whoa yeah no no no
no no no no no no it's not even no these
guys they're definitely right dude they
make they I don't agree with them
ideologically I don't agree with like a
lot of the stuff that they make
especially in regards to like trans
stuff or maybe sometimes like the oh
women are going too far like we're
against the manosphere but like
sometimes you know they're behaving like
uh weird you know that kind of stuff uh
they I think do uh way better commentary
and and way more interesting uh
commentary than uh yeah Russian fit
which is like literally [__] 14 year
old like oh you suck if you're a woman
if you speak out against me [__] you
like they're not losing insecurity in
the same way that a lot of those other
manosphere guys are for sure they're
definitely A Cut Above and that's why
they are have a
they're definitely a that's the reason
why they have a decent why are you doing
an Italian accent line What A Cut Above
we we take ourselves very seriously
peaches and cream
[Music]
the typical conservative reaction was
like oh Hassan is such a [__] he won't
play this [__] game which by the way
I did I ended up playing it that is the
funny part is I always said I would I
just simply here here here Hassan is a
giant hypocrite is the title of this
chapter
joke
I was wrong who's a massive streamer
speaking on this the only reason why I'm
not playing this game and I know a bunch
of other people are not playing this
game is because we know that it's not
worth it to get bullied endlessly and
called transphobic endlessly in it when
we have massive uh queer communities and
audiences that's it hold up
you're not playing the game because you
don't want to get called transphobic
endlessly now you know how we felt when
you kept doing that pause it uh-oh first
of all dumbasses you were being
transphobic and you [__] moved in the
video where you were claiming that I was
stupid number one can I see what they
said my commentary on it no they were
talking about like women uh uh
well it was more than that it was a more
holistic approach I looked at their
Channel I think it was over like women
uh participate trans women participating
uh in in sports but it was a more
holistic approach to their Channel
because I looked I literally key
searched Trends in their [__] uh uh
on their YouTube channel and there was
like a bunch of those like look at this
clown trans person trans yes crazy like
yeah because you're not using like the
Tesla or something doesn't mean that
you're like okay I feel that I feel that
um and I I literally was just like oh I
don't want to look at this uh they seem
transphobic and they got super triggered
by it and popped off and made like
multiple videos but
the reason why I was talking about that
that is like absolutely clip chimped and
I think they know better and they're
just going along with it to cut a
narrative here just like Ben Shapiro did
just like all these other [__]
[__] right-wingers did what I was
talking about in that situation was an
effective measure like I was talking
about boycotts decentralized boycott
movements not working I was right it was
a decentralized boycott movement against
Hogwarts and IP that is significantly
larger than JK Rowling herself and and
not married to JK Rowling at all in this
day and age even though she is
financially uh you know making she's
being financially compensated for it
that uh was a silly boycott I was
actually criticizing trans people openly
both in my community and also in general
uh the the trans people that were uh
trying to protest this and talking about
how ineffective this was and how I
actually had uh uh strategized a more
effective way to overcome this uh this
this uh PR disasters that was inevitably
going to happen by trying to raise funds
but at the time we had a disagreement it
doesn't even matter now it's been you
know long gone at this point you know
it's water under the bridge
um I have literally raised money for
Trans Charities alongside trans content
creators and legislators uh immediately
on the heels of this uh controversy
regardless but that was a that was a
commentary that I was trying to cut
which I did uh demonstrating that
something I saw I foresaw happening was
going to end up happening it was going
to end up uh was was going to unfold and
it did happen that way and yet they just
cut one [__] second of that uh you
know a 20 second clip of that and went
along with it be like he's a [__]
hypocrite they're obviously just butt
hurt at you and I operating out of bad
faith that's it
transphobic transphobic transphobic see
it's just grieving so like he was mean
to us so we're gonna yeah man you
[__] got me transphobic transphobic
transphobic transphobic transphobes
transphobic transphobic transphobic
transphobic I mean if you were having a
conversation about transphobia yeah it's
crazy it's crazy that I used the term
when I was talking about so you stream
for like eight hours I don't know how
long no I I know it's just it's it's
disingered this dude said transphobia 20
times yeah it's [__] clown Behavior
it means something I don't know what
what
didn't even make them okay okay they
didn't make a point they don't have to
because it's like [__] Hassan that's
what it is their point is [__] us on and
Their audience loves that [__] by the
way sure that situations aren't even
they're not even comparable I know I'm
literally as a you know Pro trans uh
person talking about effective ways to
to uh override a prevailing narrative
then and and demonstrated like certain
decentralized ineffective
um all you need to do is go to their
Channel and search trans and you'll
understand whether or not you know I was
wrong to make the assertion that they're
transphobic or not just do it here hey
let's do it I'll tell you what fresh and
fit if you want beef you just gotta
understand
that oh they're gonna say you're racist
but here well there's two names uh it's
peaches and cream so okay
just do it just do it press Escape
is hit the search bar I'll tell you
something guys
um I'm skinny Ethan now hit the hit the
search bar on their Channel no you're
gonna You're Gonna Lose the fat card
here pretty soon oh no and that's
everything that's all you guys have
videos go to go to videos search trans
just search Trends okay
females should fight males remove all
categories this looks like does this
look like a pro trans Channel or someone
that's like not violence Jim Chapelle
trans trans women enters a hot tub with
a mom and her six-year-old daughter
um but it's wrong with that
that's that's a freaking psychotic title
and they always like you know what's
wrong with that no this is Rage bait
it's just like anti-trans rage base
women impregnated you're doing the same
thing that like gamergate weirdos did
back in the day you're looking at like
edge cases or like random trans people
every now and then behaving in like a
[__] insane manner to be like look at
the trans people they're at it again and
that's it you're totally right trans
criminal denied entry into female prison
yeah Dave Chappelle jokes are dangerous
trans YouTubers Samantha Lux why isn't
your business transcompetent trans woman
they have a lot trans woman enters
female bathroom and this happened
how transgender athletes are straight up
lying I can't believe I made the
assumption that these guys might be
transphobic after searching Trans on
their YouTube page if you're not open to
dating a trans person transgender person
you might be guess who gets beaten up
trans women with a criminal record
enters a female Spa pansexual gender
non-conforming trans man goes on a
dating show trans woman Leah Thompson
breaks records this woman needs to work
harder women becomes a man realizes it's
very difficult yeah I mean look there's
a lot there's a lot of [__] like damn
y'all damn
damn all these
okay now these don't say transform yeah
but it's just key surgery amazing
Hassan [__] banned for using slurs
against whites oh my Lord
yeah these these dudes came out against
cracker I don't know I don't remember I
didn't watch it I I don't I don't watch
the videos uh like I said I watched like
one snippet and I was like ah not for me
and I moved on but of course you can't
just do that on a live stream you can't
even do that without 11 videos being cut
about you and then uh I'm cool who's
like constantly [__] I know what you
mean like you don't want to deal with
all that but yes I'm I'm cool with that
I'm live every day so like I'm ready
dudes with like large fan base when they
do [__] like this they're annoying ass
[__] fans come into my chat and abuse
the the egalitarian process that we have
so that like everyone can speak their
mind uh and then when they get banned
they cry about it and they're like
lifelong haters okay finish our story in
the conversation in a narcissistic way
when this [__] happens all right let's
let's move on Elon Musk yada yada it's a
psyop okay that was [__] weird uh
then he goes on George Soros posting
which is most people should know by now
is just like thinly veiled anti-semitism
he says Soros reminds me of Magneto I
didn't know that this was uh a thing
that was uh anti-semitic I I didn't I
forgot that Magneto was even like he's a
holiday he's a holocaust Survivor but
apparently this is something that like
Jewish kids in in like Middle School
would like uh have to withstand is what
they were I saw some journalists on my
timeline talking about it like they were
just like constantly called Magneto I
know I've never heard of that yeah
that's a new one yeah I didn't know that
either but what is Soros and Magneto
have in common other than the fact
they're Jewish like I don't like I don't
think that Soros can control metal with
his mind that's the mode that's the
thing that is the kind of the defining
feature of Magneto is the uh magnetic
powers it's in the name well also he's
genocidal but okay so apparently I was
informed that he is uh very wealthy
though and George Soros is and they were
both in the Holocaust if there was
anyone and so who else is very wealthy
in this conversation right that's Elon
Muslim another guy 100 times richer than
him wait that's crazy you're actually
absolutely [__] correct Ethan Elon
Musk is literally more than 10 times
wealthier than George Soros which is
crazy the billionaire wait yeah which
website is Elon Musk saying this on oh
that's right the [__] website that he
bought for 44 billion dollars which is
like that alone is like five times
sources more than five yes oh almost 10x
just the website's net worth George soar
is a [__] broke boy in comparison to
Elon Musk elon's like this dude has way
too much influence
anyway Elon goes oh you know what
apologies for this post it was really
unfair to Magneto he stole that joke by
the way from uh the The Babylon B oh he
did it Babylon B well you're gonna steal
steal from the best yeah
so then he says this was the part where
it's really weird he goes
fun fact my news experience during the
Holocaust as a Survivor shaped his
perspective as well as his depth and
empty Soros also a holocaust writer gets
attacking on stop for his good
intentions what some Americans think are
bad nearly because they disagree with
whatever Elon responds you assume they
are good intentions they are not he
wants to erode the very fabric of
society Soros hates Humanity by the way
whoa nice nuanced take there bud so okay
hold up I need to say something here
normally
I am not a big fan of billionaires okay
I'm not a big fan of billionaires I I'm
not a big fan of how much control they
have over uh politics in in a global
capitalist system I'm not a fan of
George Soros I actually despise him and
he does have a lot of ngos uh that
operate in uh whichever countries that
the United States wants to do regime
change in and that is by design that is
not an accident
so whenever someone criticizes George
Soros or whenever someone says oh that's
Soros funded I'm not always like quick
to be like oh that's anti-semitic that's
anti-Semitic
that on the other hand what Elon Musk
said right there is literally
Jewish Puppeteer memes like he just he
didn't just say oh Soros just like you
know he's funding like the open Society
Foundation or whatever and that's like I
don't like that he's finding a lot of
liberal causes that I don't appreciate
he just straight up says he wants to
erode the very fabric of civilization
Sorrows hates Humanity Sorrows a Jewish
billionaire Puppeteer wants to erode the
very fabric of civilization is verbatim
verbatim cultural bolshevism okay and
and it just straight up what the
fascists used to say and still do
obviously right that in and of itself is
like going nah I just hate your Sorrows
because he's like a Jewish guy that
wants to destroy the West is that's it
you did it you [__] said it he's
there
uh this guy responds George Soros has
been so uniquely destructive to Law and
Order in American cities that there's a
name for the Carnage he's wrought Soros
DA's his organization described his
strategy to political in 2016 article it
would change the law not by going
through legislator but dot dot dot
whatever Elon said perfectly said among
other things Soros astutely identified a
massive arbitr uh Arbitrage opportunity
and district attorney elections where a
relatively small amount of money has
outsized influence Soros instructions to
his pet prosecutors where essentially to
minimize Prosecuting even violent
criminals that's why a criminal someone
who
had already stabbed his roommate could
brutally assault Dave Chappelle on stage
with that same deadly weapon and yet
receive merely a misdemeanor yeah George
Soros was like kill Dave Chappelle
that's what George Soros wanted to do
he's pro-crime on the streets because he
wants to erode this is this is really
yeah so uh I can't speak to like uh you
know the many different uh ngos in in
Civil Society uh civil society orgs that
George Soros has funded uh in the United
States of America
and like I said all billionaires do this
[__] uh they just have like pet projects
whether because they personally believe
in it or whether because it actually
opens up an Avenue for them to seek
additional profits which is what Elon
Musk does all the [__] time for the
record
um but the Soros D.A narrative is so
[__] stupid like the idea that every
single Progressive D.A is like somehow
backed by uh George Soros to like allow
criminals to let loose and run rampant
in the [__] streets of the United
States of America is such an idiotic
concept it is mind-boggling it only
makes sense it when you think of Sorrows
as like a purely evil person like a
comic book villain yeah yeah but but the
hilarity is like
the hilarity is that America is the
worst carceral state on the planet
right we house right that's the largest
hard to square up number of prisoners on
the [__] planet
per capita more prisoners than all these
other places like China but there's no
Freedom you know what I mean so the idea
that like the population is in prison
that's insane four percent of the entire
global population lives in the United
States of America 25 of the prisoner
population is in the United States we
have a quarter of the entire planets
chained enslaved people that's living on
U.S soil doing basically [__] Free
Labor which is again protected by the
Constitution under the 13th amendment by
the way in enslaving a human being under
coercive conditions uh forcing them to
do labor under coercive conditions is
slavery and it's totally justified and
allowed in the Constitution the idea
that we have also private prisons on top
of that so there's like further profit
seeking on on the incarceration of human
beings is insane to me and most other
people that live outside of the United
States of America and yet yet the real
problem in America is not that our
criminal justice system is too [__]
psychotic bloodthirsty Draconian
ineffective in lowering recidivism but
instead not violent and brutal enough
that's or we're not arresting enough
people yeah dude everyone literally
everyone has to be around everyone
that's not Elon Musk or a billionaire or
like how can we arrest more people we've
arrested everybody yeah everybody's in
jail business owner everyone needs to be
arrested you have to just go to [__]
jail that is a great Point well here
this is when it gets really good so Elon
Musk has an interview
on CNBC business and this guy is giving
him like a softball interview oh this
guy was so first of all I don't even
know if we can show this on the new uh
YouTube term service because this is
like dick sucking to the max oh yeah
it's like this is just like straight up
uh revealed by uh shaft my good sir so
so Elon is just trembling that somebody
asked him about this and that guy if he
only if this guy only asked like one
good follow-up question it could have
been so good but what we got was good
why would he the media is not
antagonistic towards billionaires the
media is quite literally designed to
prop up the capitalist uh the capital
structure especially Elon Musk is the
personification of capitalism as a human
as a deity of capitalism so of course
this guy despite elon's like many uh
idiotic sentiments uh even reactionary
sentiments that are like uh
transparently right wing to like the the
dumbest of children he has to like
soft-serve it and try to find a way to
excuse it justify it he's not asking
that question as a gotcha here he's
asking that question to be like please
please clarify so we can so the the
Tesla stocks don't tank I want to know
how much Tesla stock that [__] piece
of [__] owns oh by the way so the yield
guys will notice when he asks he goes
why did you say this [__] about George
Soros or the smash shooter and instead
of being he goes Elon goes it's free
speech and instead of saying well why
well what's your evidence he says well
don't you think that's gonna hurt your
stock
hey let's watch yeah somebody who's
talking about the guy who killed
children in a mall in in Allen Texas
you say something like it might be a bad
psyop I'm not quite sure what you meant
but
pause it for a second
I said this I'm sorry don't go you love
pausing I do but like we're gonna run
out of time I just want to say something
here okay that statement he would never
never be this [__] uh nice if he saw
some random schlub screaming what Elon
Musk was saying which many of them do
some right wing [__] freak in like a
like a like a Baptist Church in the
South he would look at that guy with
disdain but when it's the [__] big
billionaire uh poster boy of capitalism
sitting across from you inside of his
own [__] facility inside of his own
Factory you have to be like what did you
mean by this Terry what did you mean by
this you know what he [__] meant by
it yeah you can see also Elon is like
you really [__] ask me this [__] I'll
destroy you maggot oh in that particular
case uh
there was a
a
somehow that that's not not that the the
the the
RCP of people were killed but the it was
I think incorrect yes white supremacist
action
it was some obscure Russian website that
no one's ever heard of that had no
followers that's such a weird thing you
say it's like a massive website there
yeah it is actually a popular website
which is weird that like a social media
guy doesn't know he gets that right
another social media website just not
used in America but
the company that came that found this is
bellingcat right and you know what Bella
cat does psyops right
do you think that because like you know
you're a CNBC guy do you actually think
that well even if you know that that's
true which I say that I think Bell and
Cat does uh work for the CIA and will
engage in some psyops every now and then
they are basically an arm of the [__]
State Department however do you think
that liberal guy he doesn't agree he
says I'm [__] I don't know what the
[__] you're talking about cat right and
you know what Bella cat does psyops
right right I couldn't really even he
knows exactly what it was you were I
just I don't understand I was like thank
you for the clarity oh my God right
right right oh thank you for describing
it my good sir and and uh and and not
like well he had a swastikas tattooed on
him that's why I don't understand why is
he still saying this there's no way that
he's not aware that the police are like
yeah he's covered in swastika the
journalist please couldn't you just ask
that you know what I mean like it's
right there it's right there and that
the information for that uh came from an
obscure Russian website and was somehow
magically found by valencat which is
magically
magically found by journalism
and there's no proof by the way that he
was not
there's no I would say that there's no
proof that he is yes there yes there is
is
liberal I'm so smart I don't know what
more evidence that can be other than a
story it's that's the wild part about
this is that like these guys don't
[__] hide it like the Buffalo shooter
was literally like I'm gonna go to a
black neighborhood to a grocery store
and kill as many black people as
possible uh like they openly stated they
openly show it they want people to
understand that they are doing this for
white supremacist reasons they even show
where they got radicalized whether
intentionally or unintentionally okay
and and these [__] [__] still
are like oh I don't know about that uh
yeah I don't know was he was he saying
he loves Hitler while he was shooting
people uh uh I did not checkmate at a
certain point people need like are they
gonna wake up to the fact that everybody
on the right is ready to sell them out
instantly it's like the January six
people like they're all antifa now or
whatever like these these are like right
I did it for you they did it four times
magazines and now they're being accused
of being FBI or whatever that's my
favorite Trove is it like any time one
of these like [__] basement dwelling
[__] like actually take matters in
their own hands the the same circles
that they are inside of like all the
forms that they're inside of
collectively call them like you know a
gay losers yeah so they're like nah that
guy's not that guy's not one of us he's
a gay loser psyop a CIA agent it's like
no that guy is you okay you're the same
David de Pepe they did the same [__] to
him they were like oh David oh no he's
just some gay guy he's gay he's not one
of us dude he's like no he looks and
smells exactly like you you [__]
loser
and that's a debate you want to get into
on Twitter yes
because we should not be ascribing
things to white supremacy uh if it's
false
slam dunk slam dunk journalism and then
there's more Clips I wanna uh there's a
couple more Clips they're so good the
media would [__] eat anyone else
alive dude they would be like piranhas
you know do your day with a scent of
blood that they cause easiest layup ever
yeah anyway that [__] I'm
willing to bet does not think Belle and
cat is uh doing psyups which they are or
they are funded by the National
Endowment for democracy like they are
they are a cut out of the of the state
department certainly that doesn't change
the reality that like sometimes they're
gonna do they have good journalists on
there on their payroll as well and
sometimes they do cover stories or in
many instances they cover stories uh it
might it might have a biased slant
towards like American imperialist
efforts but they still have the capacity
to cover the reality the truth
here's my favorite this one goes so off
the rails it's like really embarrassing
you know dude hurt the company are there
Tesla owners to say I don't agree with
his political position because and I
know it because he shares so much of it
or their advertisers on Twitter that
Linda Ocarina will come and say you
gotta stop man or you know I can't get
these ads because of some of the things
you tweet
oh oh he's gonna pop off oh he's gonna
pause so much of pauses he's so hot dude
he's thinking you know I'm reminded of
uh
yes there's a scene in The Princess
Bride yes great movie [__] man it's a
great movie
where
he confronts the person who killed his
father
he says
I remember that team
I remember that scene being cooler oh it
was such a cool scene I loved it
dude you're you are so incapable of
speaking holy [__] damn you just don't
care killed that line read okay hold on
hold on hold on this is important to
hear he says
offer me money
he's doing an accent too
I don't care
by the way that's not the line by the
way you're the richest one of the most
powerful people in the world I don't
think you're worried about money and
power you know he's like he's like I
don't care about of course he cares
about money 400 billion dollars of
course he cares about money and power
that's why he's a billionaire and it
like you know the the the idea that he's
like operating on some like other
spectrum of of uh genuine interest like
okay what's the genuine interest then
like doing transphobia that's what like
you're like I don't care no matter how
much you throw at me like I'm still
gonna put up non-gagmims from
2017. because he he actually I'm still
gonna post iFunny memes that only
divorce dads left I think this is the
first time in his life he's ever been
liked by people and so I think he no
he's not he does no the right they love
no I think they're he's losing favor
well I think that that is he's like he
likes on Twitter it makes him feel good
you know I think it's way more
universally yeah before yeah he was low
he was cherished them Ethan when he lost
the Mr peace vote it was [__] over
for him okay it's joover wait what was
the Mr Beast even Mr Beast was like come
on Elon you know uh oh yeah when he was
like yeah this is not you please take
your please turn off your phone I don't
care
don't yeah see you just don't care
that's not how the scene went at all
yeah I was like I love that movie I know
it really well I've never seen it and I
was like what I've never seen prison's
bride brah it's a good movie okay
whatever it doesn't share well anyway
let's finish the clip you have to say
I'll say what I want to say and if if
the consequence of that is losing money
so be it by the way Sam he's so [__]
Brave as the CEO of Tesla publicly uh
traded company I'm pretty sure that's a
violation of his fiduciary yup it don't
even matter though because he can say
whatever the [__] he wants and like the
market reacts in a way that it's not
yeah it doesn't normally react uh it's
weird
so then uh there's one there's just a
cute few more which I love by the way if
you watch some of those while I go pee
again okay the actor by the way I can't
pause who did the scene from Princess
Bride actually quote tweet it says
yeah I do not think it means what you
think it means which is a Princess Bride
quote yes and actually is relevant to
what the [__] he's talking about I love
the scene where he's confronting the man
who killed his father and he says offer
me money offer me power and he uh offer
me all the riches in the world and the
guy's like yes I'll do what you want
yeah it's like I want my father back you
son of a [__] and then stabs him holy
[__] relevance to the scenario at all
he just wanted to see him beg yeah crazy
ugh so moving on here uh Elon Musk
explains he's not anti-semitic why would
anybody think that about me
George Soros
what I'm looking for because I want to
make sure I quote it properly but I mean
you know what you wrote but you
basically it reminds me of magnetos is
like you know calm down people this is
not like metaphor explain I want to know
how he reminds you of Magneto I'm
actually would love to hear your
analysis
you said he wants uh what what I'm scary
the very fabric of civilization and
Soros hates Humanity like when you do
something like that yeah it's funny
because he goes it's just a Magneto
analogy calm down and he was well you
said he hates Humanity
that's true that's my opinion no that's
true but why share it why share it
especially I mean
why he goes not that what you're saying
is crazy right just why say it because
it's CNBC it's like it's the business
Network and so like I get it their their
angle is like your you know you're
damaging the company you're like why say
that just keep it private or whatever
yeah they don't give a [__] that he's
saying it
sure when people who buy Teslas may not
agree with you advertisers on Twitter
may not agree with you
um why not just say hey I think this you
can tell me we can talk about it over
there you can tell me I love that [__]
yo if you think your source is like a
part of the Jewish cabal tell me I love
that just not on camera right friends
but why share it widely
I mean I this is freedom of speech I'm
allowed to say whatever you absolutely
are that's such a pathetic juvenile
response like grow the [__] up idiot
is stupid [__] this is like fries like
this guy too much [__] micro dosing I
think you're right yeah I think he
you're absolutely right but I'm trying
to understand why you do because you
have to know it's got a there it puts
you in a in the middle of a
the partisan divide in the country it
makes you a lightning rod for criticism
I mean do you like that I you know
people today saying he's an anti-semite
I don't think you are no I'm definitely
I'm like I'm like a pro Semite if
anything which I don't like either I
don't like people who are like I love
Jews Jews are the greatest Jews are
great businessmen Jews are awesome those
are great with money yeah that's also
like kind of [__] up I believe that
probably is the case but why would I
even introduce the idea God he's such a
[__] clown this journalist I hate him
almost more than I hate you on and I
hate it a George Source interview no God
no then he goes let's not talk about
George Soros anymore but God know the
case I I mean it looks we don't want to
make this a George Source interview no
God no God
God no
you wouldn't want to like
new news media [__] like you wouldn't
want to do like anything that a
journalist would do in the situation
which is prodding and trying to truly
investigate why uh Elon Musk has these
kinds of resentments oh or where he
learns these things by the way if you
want to know why he's Soros posting
George Soros dumped his Tesla stock
early in the year but it was only it was
16 million or something like that but I
guess he's about heard about it but
there's one more clip and then we can uh
send Hassan on his way yeah also worth
mentioning Elon Musk was subpoenaed in
relation to Epstein JP Morgan lawsuit
that he responded to that too he
responded to like unusual whales uh
posting about it okay do we have that we
should pull that
uh unusual whale I know what you're
talking about yeah I saw that Twitter
interaction I I I'm a big believer here
he is saying that workers need to get
back in the office damn it that that
that people need to are more productive
when they're in person
um is that true and uh by research and
and and really man I
and the whole sort of work from home
thing it's like
I I I think it's I'm so mad at this
but there are some exceptions but I kind
of think that that the whole notion of
work from home is is a bit like the you
know the the fake Marie Antoinette quote
let them eat cake it's like
it's like it's like really you're going
to work
you're a billionaire you work from home
everything is your home you don't even
work you're a billionaire you're a
billionaire who claims these founded
companies because he had enough Capital
to [__] buy them you've never done a
[__] honest day of work in your
goddamn life you Emerald mind recipient
Emerald mine wealth recipient piece of
[__] apartheid [__] ass oh my God he
makes me so mad that he's like oh the
laptop generation is so lazy they're not
like my factory workers it's like [__]
you don't want to pay your factory
workers and you don't want to [__]
pay the laptop guys either so shut the
[__] up your entire existence is propped
on both the laptop guys and the [__]
Factory assembly line guys literally
generating value for you that's all you
do
[__] how is he saying
it's insane it's insane that like a
billionaire could [__] say this and
not like
I don't want to say anything TOS related
I don't have a button in front of me but
like it makes me yeah it makes me very
it it makes me very angry when I hear
the the pathetic [__] fail son who
has been propped up every goddamn step
of the way who's failed upwards who's
been elevated by by you know locking
himself into uh corporations that they
basically pushed him out of but he's
still got a tidy profit at the end of
their uh you know at the end of their
exit like PayPal and then taking that
money in like the PayPal CEO hates him
that's what I mean like he literally
lucked into everything that he did he
was a Drifter and a con man the whole
way bill is and yet so many people don't
see it because like he is idolized as a
a super wealthy billionaire guy and if
you think Elon Musk doesn't deserve uh
or didn't work harder or smarter or
especially a billion times harder
smarter than the average [__] worker
then all of a sudden this entire system
that is propped up by the LIE of
meritocracy falls apart so instead of
facing that [__] Grim reality you
just turn around and go no no no no
every every naysayer is just jealous and
stupid and a communist who's a hypocrite
probably but Elon Musk he's not
hypocritical he's actually brilliant he
has to be brilliant otherwise why the
[__] am I toiling away at my dumbass
[__] desk job where I have no
autonomy over my own life where I spend
80 of my [__] adult lives uh adult
life before I die eventually uh from the
banality of existence uh I can't think
of that I don't want to think that that
system is for nothing I want to think
that like I will too become like Elon
Musk one day and that he worked really
hard and I'm just not working hard
enough but one day I will and I'll
[__] be just like him how is it that
he can say they are so entitled to say
let them eat cake you're talking about
your employees like are you [__] this
mad everyone else who made your car come
work to the fact work in the factory
you're gonna make the people who make
your food that gets delivered that I
don't think the people building The Cars
care if the engineers work from home or
not like what the [__] are you talking
about the thing is like there are plenty
of Engineers that could work from home
and I'm sure some of them do actually
the irony of course is that like every
c-suite uh c-suite like how you say
sweet c-suite you got it sweet am I
saying right you're saying it right [__]
okay ESL uh every [__] c-level
executive and every manager is already
[__] working from home those guys get
all the freedom on the [__] planet
but God forbid you're like an entry
level position that finally has a little
bit of a crumb of [__] autonomy in
his own life all of a sudden that's like
a big No-No because we can't manipulate
you as much if you're not directly in
our line of sight you have to come in
and do the two hours of work that you
normally would do where you actually are
doing work and then the the four other
five other six other hours of just like
[__] around and like making it seem
like you're busy here in the office
rather than at home because you know
that's what we got to do because there's
commercial real estate uh he's at stake
here I I don't know what it is he needs
to feel like he owns them he wants to
feel like he's getting his worth out of
them and they're the fact that they're
living an easy life you know that they
can go [__] and have a coffee break when
they want and you know I think it's
primarily all of those things but I do
have to also point out that he is a man
who owns a car company
talking about how people it's immoral to
not commute to work every day Fair all
right that's one a little I don't know
every single person but it is fair dude
every single person including that
monkey in the suit the CNBC guy okay
they literally can they despise the work
from home uh mentality all the bosses
hate it all the CEOs hate it that's why
there's been like a hundred [__]
op-eds written on the New York Times and
Wall Street Journal about how like work
from home is destroying Society research
shows that productivity does not
decrease as a matter of fact in certain
instances increases and that the new
method is probably going to be a couple
days off couple days on I mean we know
we know whatever it doesn't even matter
though it doesn't even matter because
they come fix your house they can't work
from home but you can bro what you're so
[__] dumb everybody just because a
mechanic has to like fix on a car
physically in a garage that everybody
has to drive to work what the [__] are
you saying what other aspects is it dumb
one other aspect is
Elon Musk is right
as far as delivery drivers as far as
people in the service sector they have
to [__] go to work you should pay
them more so they should get paid fairly
they should get paid more as a matter of
fact not on the virtue of replaceability
but on how much value did they bring to
the [__] table but you won't do that
because you're a [__] piece of [__]
billionaire who designed a system that
benefits from not doing that but of
course it's all [__] it's a way to
like Drive animosity
amongst the working class it's literally
class solidarity in action with the
wealthy I don't care anymore journalists
talking to the wealthy Capital owner
billionaire where they both agree like
yeah work from home is bad right these
[__] lazy entitled pathetic work from
home guys uh real you know the people
working at the oil rig don't have to do
that well okay pay the people working at
the oil rig more that's the whole point
but they're acting like the dudes that
on the oil rigs are like dude I'm pissed
that I have to come be here physically
while everyone else gets to work from
home nobody thinks like that unless
you're a [__] freak they might be
directed to think that way if he keeps
hammering on that's the whole point
that's why he's saying it right yeah to
[__] antagonize and and create class
division that is the purpose there's a
sole purpose of sentiments like this and
he's a piece and they do it usually they
do it through racism like that's the
most effective method of like
antagonizing and and creating class
divisions uh creating divisions inside
of the labor force to like harp on the
the strings of white supremacy and be
like yeah black people are like this
they're getting a lot of benefits aren't
they what the [__] they should work
harder and then every [__] white
worker doesn't even realize that they
have the exact same
exact same material needs and material
demands from their Workforce
on the boundaries of class on the
boundaries of being [__] working
class but they they can't even think
about that because now they're focused
on the white supremacy angle I find it
interesting that he can't even really
defend the work from home other than
saying it's not fair like since when was
that an argument or anything yeah it's
not fair I've got lots of things like
yeah it's not fair yeah life isn't fair
I mean we've all heard it's a
productivity issue but it's also a moral
issue ironic it's the moral issue it's a
moral issue crazy yeah I think your
existence is a moral issue he goes never
mind productivity it's a moral issue
what what's with the word from her
[__] so frustrating I [__] hate
this mom well they do
they're still pushback by the way it's
still going on this battle is still
happening I mean leadership
organizations and I speak to plenty of
them I want people back I want people
back
three days a week they're still battling
uh it's not clear that good for them the
workers have more power people are not
coming back
the the the laptop classes living in la
la land the laptop class
oh brother yeah I love that the laptop
class professional manager class a
laptop class it's like dude what are you
wait hold on you are rushed in a laptop
class he is he's actually this is class
Warfare you're right
yeah no he's literally trying to mystify
class not on the real boundaries of like
worker proletarian versus Bourgeois
Capital owner but instead on the
boundaries of like laptop class versus
Starbucks Baristas versus service sector
workers no they all are wage laborers
they do not make money from the capital
that is accumulating in a [__] bank
account okay they are actually putting
in work they get paid a contracted
[__] wage okay and their Surplus
labor values being extracted from them
it doesn't matter if you're a [__]
auto mechanic it doesn't matter if
you're working in a white collar job it
doesn't matter if you're a [__]
marketing manager okay that's happening
to you and people can never recognize
that and create a shred of the class
solidarity that billionaires and the
[__] donkeys in the media that like
prop them up show on a daily [__]
basis if there is class war that's
happening and I truly do believe it's
happening every [__] day the reason
why so many people cannot recognize it
is because they don't recognize their
class position and constantly fight on
these idiotic newly created boundaries
along the lines of like laptop class the
work from home class that guy is a
worker but he's making more than me he's
in a union he's making more than me why
the [__] is he demanding more I'm
suffering here he should suffer too he
said crabs in a barrel mentality it's
what I like to call peasant mentality
where you justify that existence if
you're a part of the working class and
you [__] get sucked into this
billionaire propaganda you're a [__]
dumbass all right just wake up we got
one more thing here just wrap it up yeah
so Elon Musk has always said I don't
know
uh Epstein there's a photo of me in G
Lane but like I don't know her she photo
she like photobombed me well he's being
subpoenaed in a lawsuit alleging that
Epstein actually made an intro
for Elon Musk on behalf of Elon Musk II
uh Chase Bank to his like I guess
private uh Equity guy there and so they
want to know the nature of that
relationship uh Elon responded on
Twitter he says this Crete never advised
me on anything whatsoever the notion
that I would need or listen to financial
advice from a dumb crook is absurd at JP
J.P Morgan let Tesla down 10 years ago
despite having Tesla's Global Commercial
Banking business which we then withdrew
I never have forgiven them okay so
answer the subpoena instead of ignoring
it tell them that
prove it subpoena I believe was because
he was dodging it is now the they got
approval from the judge to just deliver
it to Tesla the company they couldn't
find him to serve him right he was
dodging it well they couldn't find a
server because like his live docks and
coordinates are no longer available on
Twitter
you know it's this laptop class work
from home mentality if he was in the
[__] office right then you know we'd
be able to find them yourself
you know uh this is absurd but the idea
sit down and work it is I can't I I'm
like I'm still shaking from the [__]
anger that I feel towards like the most
spoiled brat on the [__] planet
having the audacity to talk [__] about
the laptop class
that was wild that was how the [__] does
anyone agree with that God damn it
everyone's so [__] stupid I don't
know how many agree with it but uh no no
they do they look at that and go Elon is
brave bold beautiful deserves deserving
of his wealth uh definitely did it uh
through honest means uh that the system
is not flawed and yeah he is right all
those laptop class guys they're gay they
went to school they got marketing
I have an interview I need to attend I
know I know all right
wow so much to say what an app
we just got a 20 donation that said fire
up with fire emojis from David Whisperer
so much to talk about so little time the
sun is back we're back we're back hell
yeah baby we are hello Harris my friends
and uh we will be back next week to
spread more terrorism yeah correct of
the white variety oh yeah domestic
terrorism of the domestic variety
all right guys Tata love you see you
next time
foreign